ouf salut à tous on est reparti gros
match aujourd'hui stuff rond de 8 donc
on a la tête d'affiche on a Carlsen
contre pardon Caravana contre Carl Seine
dans cette ronduite donc ça c'est
vraiment l'affiche de
de la journée donc l'ensemble numéro 2
mondial contre champion du monde ouais
45 qui est quand même revenu à la faveur
de sa victoire hier et Fabiano qui nous
a poussé qui nous a fait faire un stream
de 7h30 hier c'était assez assez
incroyable avec parram ils sont vous
voyez quand même dans une position de
paramètres gagné et finalement il s'est
pris des pieds dans le tapis et aurait
dû perdre contre Fabiano qui a trouvé
des belles ressources dans dans la
finale mais il n'a pas poussé au bout ni
concrétiser sa domination en fin de
partie dommage pour lui et aujourd'hui
ça repart avec quelque choc et tu viens
de citer le grand format du jour le
carwana Carlson qui nous donne bien
envie c'est ça alors on peut faire un
petit point classement si vous voulez
avant de de vous dévoiler un peu les
appariements
donc on va avoir ici un Abdou satorrov
qui a un point et demi vous voyez pardon
qui a un point d'avance sur un groupe de
quatre et demi donc 5 points et demi sur
7 c'est quand même assez monstrueux qui
est vénère dans ce format là deux points
d'avance sur Carlson qui fait la moyenne
et dans ce temps-là c'est juste
incroyable quoi c'est ça au bout de
cette ronde c'est incroyable c'est ça en
plus
aboutrov c'était vraiment un des jeunes
qui qui monte en flèche c'est pas du
tout enfin c'était pas un des favoris
un ou deux favoris on garde scène Edding
qui ont tous les deux trois points et
demi sur 7 donc difficile en tout cas
pour eux mais en tout cas Abdou qui fait
un super début à 5 et 1000 sur 7 suivi
d'un point par carwana Guiri so et
Prague donc Prague aussi une petite
surprise qui qui fait un excellent
tournoi aussi
et du coup donc tous ces gens-là qui
attendent la faute de Rohff pour essayer
de revenir à sa hauteur à quatre points
on aura les volets ronian et à 3h30 donc
on a du coup 45 on a dit on n'aura pas
RAM à 3 points on aura irigasi à 2,5 on
aura un rapport à deux points on aura
ventes Forest et Kemer et avec un ennemi
on aura Google alors maintenant on va
voir un petit peu les appareils de la
ronde donc voilà du coup sauf qu'on peut
dire c'est capable de cette offre on a
dit hier c'est plus 23 points et l'eau
c'est ce qui est vraiment colossal à ce
niveau là c'est c'est une fortune on dit
qu'il y a un gap quand il y a un écart
de niveau significatif tous les 50
points et l'eau donc réalisé au bout de
cèderonde un plus 23 quand on est plus
de 2700 c'est rarissime pour être
signalé
et c'est surtout aussi synonyme de de
grand tu vois que généralement les
joueurs qui font plus 23 ou un tournoi
c'est qu'ils ont une très grosse
progression et puis ben ça confirme tout
ce qui fait depuis déjà quelques mois
donc en tout cas
en tout cas belle surprise pour lui donc
du coup dans cet appartement on va avoir
chaud contre Ding lin tableau 1 en son
aura Guiri contre gamer
guiret qui est qui est dans les
poursuivants de tête donc il essaiera de
de marquer un point contre Gamer pour se
rapprocher un petit peu de
Rohff qui n'est pas très en forme en
plus donc du coup là hier il a lâché une
partie hier il a fait nul contre Ding
dans une position complètement gagnante
Kevin donc il avait super bien joué
après la finale de Tours je dirais qu'il
a pas eu grande réussite puisqu'il avait
plutôt maîtrisé sur un coup tout s'est
écroulé alors que honnêtement c'était
pas si facile de voir qu'il avait fauté
tout simplement
qui est très solide qui est très
expérimenté
qui joue aussi pour le gain quand dans
cette partie donc du coup c'est une
partie qui va être intéressante
vente forest du coup contre irrigues
donc là c'est ça va être sûrement une
partie chaude c'est deux joueurs qui
vraiment joue pour le gain dans toutes
les parties les joueurs qui font pas un
excellent tournoi tous les deux donc du
coup bah je pense qu'ils ont à coeur de
ce refaire donc
on peut voir un peu spectacle dans cette
partie en tout cas en tout cas je pense
qu'on on va avoir des trucs sympas je
pense qu'on verra du H4 G4 peu importe
la position on verra des trucs partir
sur les sur les ailes ça c'est clair
ensuite on a un rapport contre Prague
donc ils sont juste l'année dernière je
me souviens que c'était une Nimzo et
Prague avait eu avait eu les Noirs donc
c'est une vente assez bizarre avec MG3
enfin attention à pas mais c'était une
limeo et Prague avec l'avantage dans
l'ouverture elle était même pas pareille
mais niveau technique il s'était fait
surclasser par rapport et donc là il se
rejoue un an après avec les mêmes
couleurs donc on va voir un peu ce qui
va se passer
ensuite on a car wanna contre karathon
ça c'est en la fille du jour on en a
parlé tout à l'heure donc Caravana qui
qui est dans la course de tête du
tournoi qui a fait une partie de 7h30
hier contre Carlsen qui lui est pas
forcément en forme mais qui vient de
battre à part donc on va voir un peu ce
qui se passe dans cette partie
et du coup Kesh qui joue contre parram
donc gogashian qui est toujours en quête
de sa première victoire contre par âme
qui lui a joué hier 7h30 pour défendre
sa nul donc fatigué par Hama
cette fatiguée donc peut-être du coup le
moment de pour Google je vais essayer de
venir chercher la victoire
donc
fais ce que tu as fait tes petits pronos
là
de tout l'énonciation j'ai profité je
suis resté tranquille dans mon coin tu
vois j'ai pris mes petites notes hier je
me suis fait un petit peu avoir tu
m'avais annoncé des pronos un peu olé
olé et finalement tu as fait ta serrure
le chat c'est pas trompé hier plusieurs
d'entre vous ont repéré le petit jeu de
stouf la petite malice donc aujourd'hui
je vais essayer d'être plus malin sauf
parce que hier c'est une journée qui m'a
coûté assez cher surtout si je considère
à nouveau la victoire d'abdu et je me
suis laissé prendre au piège quand tu as
choisi Abdou j'ai j'ai été sur Kemer
c'était vraiment pas malin de ma part
j'aurais dû enlever Abdou des pronos vu
de ces récentes en même temps sur le
papier normalement les joueurs indiens
qui sont tous plus 2007
sont aussi fort qu'abdo donc c'était
assez excitant comme comme Paris
et on en profite pour dire à salut à
tout le monde bonjour à tous
et c'est cool on revoit toujours les
mêmes il y en a qui sont discrets aussi
mais en tout cas il y en a pas mal qui
est anime le chat et c'est
particulièrement agréable de faire avec
tous ces commentaires avec vous qui
posez pas mal de questions
plus quelques petites blagues de
certains voilà dans dans le chat mais on
se régale bien et du coup oui je vais te
je vais être ambition encore aujourd'hui
au niveau de mes Paris tu vas voir tout
j'ai encore rien regardé donc là on voit
une espagnole de Caravana contre 45
alors je vais commencer à faire mes
petits pronostics excuse-moi bien sûr tu
as le droit moi tout est prêt pour une
fois sauf mais toi tu gères en plus la
technique
j'ai failli gérer la technique
aujourd'hui la stuff m'a fait une Master
Class technique mais finalement il gère
encore le stream aujourd'hui
il faut bien ça il faut bien ça on a
fait deux temps de technique et là je
deviens un technicien horaire grâce à
toi tout donc ça c'est une partie qu'on
a déjà vu c'est assez à la mode c'est
avec A4 on avait vu A5 dans une des
parties c'est la partie de saut contre
canard voilà et on a vu A5 ici
à 5 DK c'était A5 D4 la partie de
des le thème
c'était comme ça exactement la partie de
gamer
et avec ces 5 je crois Dame des trois
Tourbet 5
tours d'en prendre
8 et là on a des purement du cavalier
des œufs je me suis un peu exactement et
des deux c'est assez sec
et il y avait eu un cavalier peut-être
F3 je me suis un peu de la suite pour te
dire
bon je sais plus on verra bien ce qui va
se passer elle avait été assez
exceptionnelle d'ailleurs
très bien joué mais avec a fait dans une
position ce qui est un peu le cas tous
les jours il joue très bien Kemer mais
il arrive pas à concrétiser aussi ses
efforts ces positions
en tout cas même un petit peu logique
variante aujourd'hui on n'a pas des
quatre
mais on a C3 qui est aussi une façon de
traiter la position
en tout cas le coup à 4 et réalisé pour
éviter éviter le Marshall qu'on
connaissait pendant longtemps avec le et
ces trois dessins et A4 comme H3 ou 8e
crew voilà c'est position d'anti
Marshall
donc il y a une carrocane de Digne pour
l'idiot il me semble que l'idiot joue
aussi la carrocane
et du coup ça ça lui fait bien plaisir
est-ce que tu as oui je t'en prie sauf
pardon
[Musique]
je suis trop bon aujourd'hui on va voir
tu sais du coup
c'était pas encore commencé les pronos
je t'aurais influencé en me disant que
c'est la marque mettre dans un zéro de
partout
alors
ok je vais faire un truc trop beau là
donc on vous rappelle un saut dignemer
Abdou aronia van foo reste
erikasi rapporte Prague carwana Karlsen
et gokesh contre max
hier soir et du coup tu penses que je
peux avoir Néandertal peut-être on verra
oui acheter catalan je suis bien
d'accord avec toi ce tournoi de ta fille
et magnifique de super partie entre tous
ces champions depuis 7 jours oui
c'est assez monstrueux les parties qu'on
a vu
en partie lente de toute façon entre ces
super joueur qui tourne à plus de 90% de
bon coup voire plus de 95% de coût de la
machine sur certaines très bonnes
parties après attention quand vous avez
des fois plus de 90% ça peut être une
excellente note quand la partie ultra
complexe toutes les parties ne se
ressemblent pas à ce niveau là elle est
partie on va dire plate logique où les
joueurs vont quasiment jouer
parfaitement et quand c'est le gros
bazar forcément ils font plus de fautes
ça c'est logique et encore faute c'est
plus des impressions que des fautes
réelles il y en a peu des photos
je suis prêt
ok alors du coup comment on fait de
toute façon qu'est-ce que tu as mis
en fait j'ai un peu en fait j'ai joué
beaucoup plus solide qui a que des nuls
à part Giri qui bat très Kemer et Van
ferest qui battrait
j'ai fait un tableau qui est vraiment
beau
il n'y a pas de joueuse actuellement à
plus de 2700 Elo la meilleure jeune
femme c'est oui fan à 2650 à peu près
mais qui est beaucoup plus en retrait
depuis un moment voilà et les autres
meilleurs femmes sont aux alentours de
2600 et l'eau qui n'est effectivement
pas suffisant pour prétendre participer
à ce tournoi là dans le challenger
tu as la jeune et ligne Roberts
qui est un des plus petits lots
du tout droit de challenger puisqu'elle
n'a que 23 60 qui a un petit niveau pour
participer au Challenger mais elle vend
elle défend vraiment très très bien
ses chances même si elle n'a que deux
sur 7 elle a plutôt été mal payée donc
elle a été champion du monde des moins
de 14 ans elle est aussi
une des locales de l'étape puisque elle
est hollandaise
donc elle a été invitée aussi
de ce fait là ça lui permet de prendre
de l'expérience il y a par contre
plusieurs femmes dans le monde qui
pourraient être très bien classé dans le
challenger en tout cas avec le hello
moyen
non mais 2 sur 7 c'est
je sais pas trop malade c'est deux sur
ça c'est pas si mal franchement à 23,50
dans le challenger franchement c'est
hyper fort le challenger ça s'appelle
charger mais c'est un tournoi où il y a
de très très forts joueurs
honnêtement elle a eu plusieurs
plusieurs parties qui sont
mal terminés je crois que c'est contre
birson je crois qu'elle avait vraiment
encore une position gagnante bon bref il
y a eu plusieurs plusieurs choses
alors du coup stuff toi tu es prono
s'il te plaît je finis de me mettre
c'est mon petit truc mais
bien sûr parce qu'en fait
5 minutes même pas
oui
mais elle avait elle avait démarré par
par une victoire enfin en tout cas elle
avait vraiment très très bien démarré et
ça aurait pu super bien tourner alors
que là le cale un petit peu
c'est pas facile tous les jours quand
vous avez un petit hello et que vous
vous êtes dans un tour comme ça vous
êtes quand même ciblé
tous les joueurs veulent gagner
ouais
qui dit on aura encore le droit à la
créativité de stouffe pour la
réalisation ou pas je crois qu'il a
particulièrement aimé le petit moment
hier où tu es un peu changé la scène je
crois que Néandertal et c'est le genre
de petites choses qui est il aime
d'ailleurs on a un peu craqué au bout de
cette heure de stream on pouvait plus
mais écoute son instrument encore une
fois long et ben tu auras souvent droit
à ma créativité
alors thomios effectivement ça dépend
alors Tommy on se dit il nous demande
Souf qu'est-ce qu'on conseille aux gens
ordinaire pour monter en halo est-ce
qu'on fait plutôt des tournois très
forts ou alors
plutôt des tournois dans sa moyenne élo
globalement genre citer 1750 est-ce que
tu fais un open b - 1800 ou est-ce que
tu essaies de faire l'opena si tu en as
la possibilité à titre perso tout au
long de ma vie de joueur d'échec j'ai
essayé de faire des tournois plus fort
que moi voire même des fois beaucoup
plus fort que moi quand j'avais fait
l'accession qui est un tournoi moins de
200200 que j'étais 1900 et Champions
League que j'avais le droit de faire la
session et c'était chaud parce que
c'était pas pas forcément évident mais
parce que j'avais pas le hello Reiki
mais c'est énorme en matière
d'expérience par contre tu mets quelque
chose d'intéressant Thomas
quitte un petit jeune de 10 ans c'est
peut-être pas la peine de l'envoyer au
casse-pipe trop vite parce que faut pas
le dégoûter l'aspect confiance en vous
et aussi important maintenant si vous
êtes adulte ou aller plus de 12-13 ans
je pense qu'on peut y aller on peut
aller essayer de se frotter à des
tournois difficiles si on accepte si on
sait quand même par avance qu'on fera
peut-être même pas la moyenne quoi on
sait tout ça mais on y va pour
progresser aux échecs les premiers
titres aux échecs c'est 2300 hello donc
avant on doit aller se faire plaisir
alors est-ce qu'on obtient un plaisir en
faisant plein de victoires contre des
joueurs modestes ou en allant faire des
tours plus forts dans une démarche de
progression c'est à chacun de voir
quelles sont ses objectifs
mais pour parler de la progression long
terme je crois vraiment qu'il faut aller
chercher une adversité importante je
suis assez d'accord avec toi moi j'ai
toujours recommandé aux gens de faire le
tour le plus le plus fort qui peuvent
bien sûr dans la mesure où c'est pas
trop
trop dur quoi tu vois quand bien sûr
moi je me souviens au fige on avait de
petits Pragues qui étaient venus jouer
et il avait il avait 1900 euros je crois
et il a demandé de faire le a et donc le
a c'est plus de 2100 tu sais et du coup
ramènes tu l'as bien Romu non mais oui
tu le mets dans le bas pour mieux mais
tu es sûr 1900
en fait entre temps il a échangé des
lots il a il est arrivé à 2000 2010 un
truc comme ça il avait donc il a
commencé avec 2010 en fait le tournoi de
enfin l'Open as qui veut c'est plus de
non c'est plus de 2002 mais en 2100 et
2002 tu peux choisir où tu veux mais
c'est plus 2002 donc 2010 c'est un peu
maigre quand même et il a fait une arme
de maître voilà il a fait une dame de
maître et son éloïs
après le tournoi après le tournoi après
il avait quasiment 2400 €
et parce qu'il a fait c'est tranche
fille et puis bon en fait et puis enfin
il était déjà film mais en fait il a
fait enfin il a gagné 300 points ou 200
mois par tournoi t'imagine quand tes
coefficient 40
tu as 2010 tu fais une norme de mètres
tu dois gagner 300 points quoi
je vois très très bien sauf puisque j'ai
joué de deux super monstres en Open j'ai
joué Sarine à 22,80 et Douda pareil à
22,80 donc il se décroche à plus ou
moins 5 points lo mais et au classement
suivant il se fait 24 80 donc tu vois
c'était vraiment des appareils de merde
il y a pas d'autres mots franchement
et
d'ailleurs j'ai perdu les deux parties
deux fois avec les blancs en plus et
sans sont des jouets c'est avec les
petits étaient bons et j'essaie de bien
jouer les parties étaient pas dégueu
mais ils ont bien joué avec moi et ils
m'ont battu à la rivière
c'est dur quoi
mais maintenant tu es tu es un dire
compagnon d'équipe avec eux
les joueurs indiens et du coup avec
farine je crois hein il était tout petit
en plus tu vois il était vraiment bien
[Rires]
tu sais qui est battu un grand match
fait nul avec un grand maître donc je
savais que c'était dur et déjà quand
j'ai vu l'appareil mange aussi un vent
et après j'ai fait un mauvais choix
d'ouverture j'ai joué la ligne que je
jouais habituellement il était
extrêmement bien préparé et j'aurais pu
être plus malin et jouer un choix un peu
plus rare sachant qu'il était quand même
il avait 11 ans ou 12 ans bon c'était
c'était le bon moment pour changer un
petit peu des lignes habituelle
150 points hello dans un dans un tournoi
attention l'idiot tu as dû en prendre à
quelques-uns qui sont peut-être dans le
chat
on va aller sur les échiquiers on va
faire le tour des échiquets bookers
une
faiblesse dans le camp des Noirs tout à
fait normale sauf on a touché la dame
avec le A4 à 5 des blancs et on pourra
effectivement travailler comme nous dit
le fou va peut-être rebondir en C4 pour
travailler autour de la cible en A6
voilà il y a plusieurs plusieurs plans
et les Noirs ont une tour en B8 par
rapport à la tension existante ça c'est
plutôt bien pour eux on voit qu'il y a
l'avantage d'espace pour les blancs
c'est une Espagnole d'échange enfin
d'échange la ligne qui est assez à la
mode tout à fait donc ici il y a le
fouet 5 cavalier F6 des 3
et du coup le fameux français 6 donc
quel est les deux petits rock et
cavalier B3 donc ça n'a pas mal de
parties comme ça
ils sont un peu à la mode ici
donc
voilà en fait plus blanc pour la
structure c'est le meilleur structure
mais il y a une paire de fou vous voyez
donc c'est le prix à payer
ok ensuite on a carvana
45e
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup cette
variante à niveau amateur parce que
beaucoup d'amateurs font ces trois
souffles c'est une des variantes que je
conseille d'ailleurs dans le pack que
j'ai fait sur la carroscan parce que si
je joue ces trois on va pouvoir
travailler avec ses prends des cartes et
cavaliers C6 directement sur le pion des
4 et faire mal on pouvait faire cailler
ces 6 directement aussi d'ailleurs et du
coup ça va être une Française améliorée
puisque notre fou peut sortir en F5 ou
en G4 ça dépend c'est cavalier en F3 ça
c'est super
mauvaise pièce quoi donc là on est quand
même assez content et c'est pour ça que
du coup dépend des stand c'est le coup
de théorique après il y a plein de coupe
aussi mais c'est vrai que la vente A3
c'est une bande qui est à la mode elle
est très bien on fait des fois aussi la
cavale F3 des fois
moi aussi je joue pas ça moi je joue pas
E5 avec les blancs mais je l'avais
travaillé aussi sec cavalier froid c'est
la lune que je connaissais avec un cabas
excessif à trois B4 et cetera
mais l'idée c'est un peu la même oui à
trois B4 C4 on pourrait faire avec les
Blancs et
du coup d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est plus
ou moins joué ici le pion E6
c'est pas une attaque de nuit il me dit
tu as confondu avec une position
on pourrait mettre la position stouf
pour l'exemple je crois confondu à
cavalier ses trois ici cavalier F6
E5 cavalier 7 et là tu plantes E6
l'attaque de nuit que vous connaissez
peut-être parce que c'est un des grands
classiques des échecs on sacrifie un
pion pour la taxe sur le roi et la
structure de pion affaibli des noirs et
on coincé les noirs avec leurs pièces
vous voyez ils sont bloqués
du coup la grand style se trouve donne
sa dame voilà pour vous montrer le motif
donc
voilà il y a un gros problème donc si ce
n'existe pas ici donc A3 faut prendre B4
fois 7 et là du coup on peut jouer avec
vous b2c4 cavalier F3 c'est des
pollutions moi je sais toujours bien
aimé les blancs dans ces positions là
parce qu'il y a plus d'espace après
c'est une question un peu de goût et de
mais moi j'aime bien cette position pour
les blancs cet homme G4 ce qui peut être
intéressant qu'elle a créé depuis le sac
qui forcerait un G6 ou un G5 peut-être
même
un peu mais bon c'est compliqué cette
structures tu vois normalement je sens
que c'est pas un goût qu'on fait
derrière etc vous voyez mais là du coup
c'est pour prendre l'espace on veut
chasser la dame et contrôler un petit
peu
en plus il y a aussi l'idée
c'est qu'en plus le pion E5 des blancs
il peut être un peu des fois affaibli vu
que le plan de 4 est parti et que du
coup F4 c'est pas forcément toujours un
bon coup parce que ça ouvre quand même
les cases noires etc et du coup le fait
de juger ça aide aussi mine de rien à
empêcher un peu un peu F4 pour plus tard
affaiblir un peu le pion 5 etc donc
plein d'idées il y a même du F5 qui peut
peut-être bon il y aura échec mais dans
l'idée j'explique je montre juste que
sur la prise de cavaler prend j'ai un
développement qui est ultra
ultra rapide
donc voilà il faut 7 donc en tout cas
c'est une partie qui va qui va séparer
je pense parce que c'est une partie où
tu vois niveau structure on est quand on
a quand même
espagnol ou italien c'est vraiment
quelque chose un peu différent donc ça
c'est sympa
de critique en tout cas j'invite les
joueurs de karaoké on a regardé cette
partie parce que la ligne est très
intéressante pour les noirs
alors du coup
Guiri gamer donc c'est une c'est une
italienne
on a déjà vu ce type de position
avec un
mais
évidemment à moins il pourrait y avoir
une rupture
H4 plus trop si on a rocket
on pourra jouer pour l'espace à l'aile
dame au centre aussi un jour peut-être
des quatre et on n'a pas de problème de
Fougères il y a pas de pas de
problématique là dessus donc le roi noir
bah pour l'instant il n'y a pas trop de
pièces qu'il embête il y a pas trop
d'accès mais il faudra y faire attention
sur le long terme donc je comprends que
pour des joueurs amateurs c'est un petit
peu bizarre puis on a le plan qui avalé
C4 cavaliers E3 ou cavalier F1 cavaliers
pour un jour trouver la case F5 qui est
très faible ici ça c'est un des points
clés de la position
après un plan que nous avons donné
Mathieu combien fois c'était cavalier H7
pour juventuellement du H5 position ou
même au Rabbou j'ai pu faire F5 aussi
après que même des fois H4 avec les
Blancs pour y aller aussi donc c'est
compliqué ces positions et sur G4 on
enlève nous-même notre cavalier enfin si
ton cavalier est parti parce que pour
l'instant il y a des H5 j'ai pas envie
de me prendre g4k mais si le cavalier F6
pas on peut on a le droit aussi de
contrer de jouer H4 G4 et des fois on
voit le cavalier 3 qui part et on fait
le pion F une fois qu'on a joué H1 F4 ça
peut aussi être des contre classique
de la tour et ça me fait
alors dis-nous tout parce que moi écoute
je les ai donc je m'en fous en fait mais
attends juste et la quarantaine il y a
pas de nul enfin à ton niveau t'inquiète
risque il y aura pas ça donc il y a pas
de souci pour la quarantaine c'est tout
à fait le choix pour tout le monde
tenu avant le 1 07 2005
oula devront avoir été enregistré auprès
de la feed avant ok où elles sont
considérés comme expirées
toutes demandes de s'inclure
au moins une heure
s à l'époque les normes elles expiraient
au bout de 10 ans et maintenant elles
sont à vie donc du coup ce qui dans ton
premier est là un 5 5 c'est il explique
que du coup il faut avoir enregistré etc
voilà et ensuite avant les normes tu
pourras en faire
dans n'importe quel tournoi
par exemple moi j'en avais deux normes
EN je fais deux normes en équipe en N1
et du coup on me disait que je pourrais
faire une troisième langue en N1 s'il
voulait à condition que dans un des
trois tournois et ben j'ai suffisamment
de nationalité tu vois alors que
normalement quand tu es en équipe t'as
pas forcément besoin de nationalité
et maintenant ça a changé il faut au
moins un open ou au moins pour enfermer
un truc comme ça et bon enfin en ce qui
me concerne j'ai deux normes en équipe
et trois en Open
je suis bien tu imagines j'ai 5 normes
en équipe et je peux pas être maître
quoi un moment donné je vais écrire à la
suite quoi mais bon alors les pronostics
pas
un tournoi individuel au système suisse
dans lequel la liste des participants
comprend à chaque ronde en 40 joueurs
oui donc tu veux dire que Quentin il
faut que ce soit vraiment dans les gros
tournois c'est à dire les petits open
confidentiel sera plus dur de réaliser
des normes si je comprends bien ça
pourquoi ils font chier comme ça
je sais pas quoi
c'est pas suffisamment dur avec toutes
les conditions qu'il faut les étrangers
et quitteraient tu vois pour mettre
encore des trucs compliqués
[Musique]
mais pourquoi tu vas casser les pieds
bon bref dans tous les cas Kevin et
Jamel et moi ça me concerne plus
donc mais ouais c'est voilà
bon on va finir ce petit tour du coup
dans quelques jours
je garde le suspense
jusqu'au bout en tout cas je te dire une
chose Kevin tu vas prendre cher mais je
garde le suspense
cavalier F1 donc là c'est une italienne
italienne standard on va voir G3 petit
rock et puis etc donc il a changé parce
que la dernière c'était une une nimo
entre ces deux joueurs
ventes Forrest la partie qu'on a dit que
c'est là sympa donc c'est une sorte de
destin indienne
ça a commencé par une Anglaise
c'est la touffe voilà
parce qu'en fait généralement quand moi
je mangeais des quatre
moi qui vous cache c'est sur H3 par
exemple que tu manges un des quatre et
éventuellement sur sur quoi même si
c'est pas forcément l'idéal mais j'ai
une ligne en fait sur Tours 8 et la tour
B1 on peut manger des quatre en cinq
lignes c'est pas mal et du coup il y a
pas eu de rebut de Tours
et ton plan c'est de jouer avec A6 V5
et c'est assez intéressant c'est lignes
pour les noirs
de toute façon de comprendre pourquoi il
a mangé ici ok on va voir donc il tombe
bien apprise
cavalier prend c'est 6 grands Perceval
et pour le titre de j'aime comme on l'a
dit dans dans les différents streams que
ce soit stouf ou moi-même on a beaucoup
de travail avec les cours et on joue du
coup beaucoup moins qu'on ne le faisait
avant particulièrement pour ma part
puisque je joue un tournoi par an la
division 1 et c'est insuffisant pour
prétendre
à quelque chose d'un point de vue type
de Grand Maître ou quoi que ce soit ça
fait 10 ans ça fait depuis 2009 que je
suis 24 50 et que je bouge à pas
beaucoup quand même autour autour de cet
hello il y a des petites variations mais
qui sont assez neutres effectivement il
faudrait que je m'y remette complètement
mais ça voudrait dire arrêtez mes cours
par exemple ou vraiment les faire
beaucoup moins ça sera un changement de
vie et on discutait un des contraintes
perso avec stouf ben moi j'ai une petite
fille
peut-être qu'un jour j'aurai un deuxième
enfant bref du coup vous comprenez que
partir un peu partout en Europe pour
faire des tournois c'est extrêmement
compliqué à gérer il faudrait à peu près
8 semaines de disponibilité
supplémentaires ça veut dire huit
semaines de vacances mais vous êtes en
solo vous n'êtes pas en vacances avec
votre famille etc donc vous comprenez
bien pour tous ceux qui qui sont actifs
par ailleurs
que c'est compliqué à mettre en place
voilà il faut il faut tout faire en même
temps
donc du coup c'est un gars normal
et dans la partie c'est Google
donc on a eu un petit T4
H6 Kevin
je connais pas ça n'existe pas vraiment
le coup joué par par McDo je sois pas ça
serait étonnant que ce soit utile dans
toutes les positions très étonnantes
en france pour faire des normes
là tu regardes juste le Festival des
Jeux à Cannes qui va commencer
j'ai vu ta ta vert je regardais quelques
jours tu avais genre plus de 15 grands
mètres et 35 mètres
donc si avec ça tu as 50 titres enfin
quand les 50 titrés sont compter les
maîtrise tu peux pas faire dedans c'est
qu'il y a un problème donc il y a
qu'appelle aussi tu as Cap d'Agde tu as
quand même pas mal de tournois qui ou tu
peux faire faire des normes
[Musique]
80 quasiment qui était quand même
monstrueux enfin c'était génial quoi et
moi j'ai fait appel j'avais 2200 9 je me
souviens et j'étais 2ème élo
avec 2200
et donc est-ce que Julien song souvent
on a fait nul et il m'a battu une fois
et je l'ai battu une fois en un coup
voilà aussi en un coup il est pas venu
en match par équipe je rappelle pauvre
Julien je l'ai pas revu du coup parce
que j'étais parti prendre mon train et
j'ai gagné en une heure parce que je
l'ai attendu et il n'est pas venu il est
venu bien plus tard voilà donc
disons que oui enfin j'ai un petit une
petite avance au hello voilà après
Julien s'est remis à jouer
Julien je l'ai connu alors qu'il était
ultra rapide jusqu'à 2003 et ensuite son
titre de Maître après il a plus ou moins
arrêté les échecs ou les il en faisait
beaucoup moins et là il est reparti
voilà pour pour jouer à nouveau des
tournois et Mathieu cornette est-ce que
c'est un gros bosseur par rapport à nous
oui Mathieu c'est un gros bosseur bon je
pense qu'on bosse tous mais Mathieu
c'est un il est plus joueur pour nous je
l'ai dit c'est le numéro 1 dans ma
catégorie et Mathieu a été multiple
champion de France dans ma catégorie et
il a eu envie de passer joueur pro du
coup c'est ce qu'il a fait dans un
premier temps et après on voit qu'il y a
une telle densité de forts joueurs même
si l'approche les 2600 par moments que
c'est difficile de vivre uniquement en
étant joueur d'échec en 2600 donc
maintenant il fait des cours et il fait
il fait du jeu en plus mais c'est
principalement les les cours et les
vidéos qui sont ces sources de revenus
après ce serait à lui de s'exprimer
là-dessus mais je pense qu'il a il a une
envie de jouer plus forte et plus
légitime que la nôtre parce que bah il
est grand maître de de premier plan en
France mais dans le monde
il reste plus confidentiel parce que le
niveau requis
est important quoi on voit qu'il y a que
mvl et Ali resa qui arrive
non mais tienne Bacro et Laurent
Freyssinet font d'autres choses voilà
bah il est propre
non je joue pas trop aux échecs en tout
cas non je parle d'échec pour gagner de
l'argent
enfin dans le sens que oui si tu vas
faire quoi mais c'est pas mon boulot
quoi
prendre par cœur il est moins dans la
compréhension non il a les deux en fait
bien sûr
il a les deux il est très impressionnant
alors je peux vous dire ce que ce que
j'en pense très impressionnant dans le
calcul je l'ai suivi depuis tout jeune
[Musique]
en tactique en calcul et en ouverture
effectivement en point améliorer ça
serait peut-être la stratégie mais c'est
des stratégies de de haute volets et
c'est pas facile de l'expliquer de le
vulgariser les manques là encore sera
lui de s'exprimer je pense qu'il se
connaît très bien mais il est très très
impressionnant en calcul n'oublions pas
qu'en 2016 il a été champion de France
quand même donc c'est pour montrer que
pour être champion de France faut tout
avoir maintenant les joueurs se doivent
tous d'être universel
mais effectivement ce serait plutôt dans
l'approche statique comme nous dirait un
joueur comme Dorfman que Mathieu doit
pouvoir faire des progrès et pour pour
l'aider ça serait bien qu'il soit pro à
100% qui est impossible dans notre
milieu parce qu'on a dit il faut
vraiment être dans les dans le top 50
top 100 mondial pour vraiment très bien
en tout cas ça a pris un Néandertal qui
dit quoi c'est qui qui souligne que
c'est pas facile de juger de juger les
grands pro c'est vraiment pas facile de
de leur trouver des défauts c'est en
plus Mathieu il est hyper curieux et il
veut tout ça enfin non tout ce qui fait
c'est de comprendre quoi enfin les
subtilités pourquoi ça devient là il
fait ça alors
il comprend très très bien ce qu'il joue
et c'est pas que du Parker mais après
des fois dans les variantes et ben il y
a du Parker c'est normal à ce niveau là
et voilà quand c'est plus plus étendu
plus plus par cœur sinon
[Musique]
il y a surtout la compréhension et
souvent c'est de comprendre ce qu'il
faut faire ben tu retiens plus
facilement en fait donc en fait il y a
tout si tu apprends par cœur mais
qu'après tu comprends rien je peux plus
faire un moment donné au bout d'un au
bout d'un certain temps bah tu vas
oublier les variantes quoi alors que
c'est du comprends pourquoi tu fais
telle ou tel coup bah c'est beaucoup
plus facile en fait de retrouver plutôt
la variante donc
il disait que bon même vert il y a une
quasi mémoire parfaite enfin mémoire en
tout cas exceptionnel et il disait qu'en
fait ce qui est dur aux échecs c'est de
comprendre les nuances dans les
ouvertures des fois c'est la même
position avec un tout petit détail
supplémentaire et il faut bien intégrer
parce que ça change tout à la position
très très chaud
pas mal de risques que tu nous dis je me
demande de plus en plus si le haut
niveau devrait peut-être jouer en 960
avec stouf on a adoré commenté le cheval
du monde de Random de chasse on se fait
régalé
et c'est vrai que ça avait un vrai
intérêt
c'est écrire dès le départ
la problématique c'est que je pense que
si les joueurs commencent à jouer en 960
très vite ça serait théorisé et comme
ils ont une très bonne mémoire bah ça
irait un petit peu moins loin sauf la
théorie mais il y aurait il y aurait
quand même des bonnes préparations ouais
en tout cas des idées qui sortiraient un
petit peu moi j'ai adoré le
j'ai adoré le chocolat qu'on avait
commenté ensemble je peux habillement de
nouvelles idées qu'on a préféré enfin je
sais pas on avait vraiment trop rigolé
parce que c'était
ouais on s'amusait avec tout autour du
jeu vraiment c'était incroyable
vraiment trop sympa quoi
et on met ça en comparaison du Blitz du
rapide du championnat du monde qui sont
des beaux événements des speechers qui
sont des très beaux événements très
impressionnants le randomest était quand
même quelque chose en termes de
créativité on a assisté à des idées au
clavier
j'avais fait quoi on m'avait dit c'était
un truc un réglage qu'on m'avait dit de
faire au niveau du clavier
au niveau du clavier il va un son
c'était quoi
suppression du bruit nous dit 213 DZ un
crisp
ah j'étais remplacé par voyez
déjà fait c'est bizarre que là du coup
le son reviennent chez vous parce que du
coup je la verrai je l'avais
une fois
de se gaver dans le chat il dit que tu
es sur minitel et ensuite il se moque de
de la suppression du bruit parce que en
fait c'est ma tête qui est giclée voilà
et
du coup pour en revenir à ces positions
on voit toujours que il y a un petit
plus pour les blancs avec un bon jeu de
pièces pour Fabiano Caruana compenser
par une meilleure structure sur le long
terme pour les Noirs parce qu'il y a le
pion C3 mais puis on sait trop il a
boîte isolé et pas facilement attaquable
donc ça ça joue complètement cette pause
qui est aussi un problème sur le long
terme
et
on a vu quatre parties on n'a pas vu
tout le monde encore sauf pour continuer
notre petit tour des stades est-ce que
tu voulais du coup mais pronostics
[Rires]
j'ai rien changé par rapport à par
rapport à tu vois donc alors attends je
vais te dire en gros toi tu m'as annoncé
que tout le monde faisait nul sauf
guerrier qui gagnait contre gamer et Van
forest qui va être magazine
c'est ça
gagnant aussi ok j'ai marqué Abdou
aronia nul
et
même si même si c'est vrai que
ok bon
j'ai marqué gagnant par contre OK
et après j'ai marqué nul rapport nul
Carvin et j'ai marqué Google gagnant
et il manque le sauting
que j'ai pas entendu
[Musique]
tu sais que c'est bon enfant ici je
dirais pas ça évidemment si je perds le
pari
bonne
semble logique
comme ça mais je vais pas
profiter du fait que je l'ai vu avec toi
Erika easy et
Goo cash
c'est ça
on va voir
et
on va ce qu'on devrait non
fr qui a été plusieurs fois en France
qui sont Bauer qui a souvent des
positions moins bonnes mais qui calcule
énormément après l'ouverture
c'est pas le style contraire quand même
de Mathieu mais effectivement
Mathieu est plus juste dans ses choix
d'ouverture
Christian accepte des ouvertures plus
fantasques
je pense que Mathieu serait très capable
de faire ça mais il considère que en
termes d'efficacité c'est un choix
beaucoup plus payant de travailler les
ouvertures à fond
Christian Bauer n'a pas voulu
se farcir ce travail là pour moi et il
joue différemment ça peut-être été un
frein ça progression alors Christian
Bauer c'est quelqu'un que je respecte
énormément aussi au même titre que
Mathieu et chicanement parlant mais ça
aurait peut-être été un point
d'amélioration justement que Christian
joue des ouvertures
plus crédible mais en même temps c'est
un des seuls joueurs à pouvoir jouer des
ouvertures fantasmes parce qu'il est
très très créatif après j'aurais aimé
voir si c'était possible de de faire
aussi bien en termes de créativité mais
d'être un peu peut-être plus juste par
rapport à ce qui se fait en termes
d'ouverture faudrait en discuter avec
lui ça serait ça serait un débat
on pourrait inviter plusieurs personnes
Christian Bauer Mathieu Cornette et mvl
autour d'une table ronde c'est quand
même vla à lui choisir la justesse des
ouvertures ce sont il n'a pas le choix à
son niveau mais il y a toujours eu le
débat autour de ses choix d'ouverture
c'est-à-dire que il a beaucoup joué la
grenfeld et par rapport aux autres
joueurs de très haut niveau qui change
beaucoup mvl était très fidèle en terme
de d'ouverture ce qui faisait qu'il se
prenait des énormes préparations voilà
donc
il y a beaucoup de choses à en dire
beaucoup de choses à en dire
moi j'ai pas le choix Bruno je suis dans
la créativité
après pour se préparer quand contre un
joueur comme Christian hower c'est dur
quand tu ouvres que quand elle est
blanche contre lui il joue absolument
toutes les ouvertures
et plusieurs lignes dans toutes les
ouvertures c'est ça se décourageant
et
d'ailleurs ben j'avais fait ma quatrième
dame de maître là-bas
même en perdant
et
si je
fais un résultat je vais terminer
vraiment très très bien en tournoi et
bon malheureusement j'ai perdu au bout
de 6h30
dans une position où c'est moi qui
poussais j'avais une finale que je
pouvais peut-être gagner et il est très
piégé
et enfin je me suis embarqué un peu tout
seul
et
mais il avait hyper bien joué la finale
j'ai fait une grosse erreur et ça
perdait pas encore mais en pratique
c'est trop dur pour moi c'était une
étude quoi je te levais
et
il avait gagné mais vraiment quand je me
souviens la veille j'avais je contrôle
lui j'ai regardé je vois la base de
données j'ai je regardais ce qui jouait
je te promets la prépa la durée 10
minutes même pas je vais regarder j'ai
regardé j'ai vu ok moi je vais faire 4
sur 4 il joue
bah il joue
plusieurs fois
il a joué karaoké plusieurs siciliennes
différentes il joue
la fille d'ardeur il a écrit un bouquin
sur la file d'or il joue la pierre il
joue la française plein de françaises
différentes il joue 85 il joue la laine
il joue la Scand en fait il joue tout
tout tout tout tout et sur tout ce qu'il
joue et ben il joue plusieurs lignes
différentes et du coup je me suis dit
mais tu sais quoi j'ai vu tout ça je dis
allez on va se coucher bien sûr et en
fait je me barre pareil quoi j'ai rien
fait moi c'est ma découragé flamme c'est
le c'est pour ça qu'il est très fort
contre on va dire ceux qui ont un hello
plus faible que le sien je vois très
bien ta problématique puisque j'ai fait
la même prépa c'est à dire que c'est ma
dernière partie officielle en date
contre Christian
et donc ma prépa était un peu similaire
à tienne moi je me suis préparé aussi
jusqu'au premier coup voilà et j'ai
décidé de jouer des quatre par contre
voilà mais et d'ailleurs j'ai plutôt
dominé Christian mais qui m'a battu à la
fin sur une erreur de calcul quand
j'étais en passe j'avais 10 minutes
contre 5 en plus dans le zaynote et
j'avais aussi plus deux mais un plus de
pas évident donc c'était pour moi un bon
plus Christian n'était pas trop d'accord
mais on vérifie avec l'ordi
mais peut-être que des fois l'ordi vous
indique une valeur donc supérieure donc
avantage pour vous et Christian à
l'époque ce qui était assez intéressant
à l'époque enfin il y a quelques mois il
considère que sa position était plus
facile à jouer vrai semblablement donc
c'est assez assez intéressant aussi ces
joueurs qui ont une super compréhension
mais en tout cas Christian super joueur
et c'est pas facile pour nous de se
préparer contre des joueurs comme ça par
contre le bémol c'est quand il joue des
joueurs à 26-27 qui sont calés sur
toutes ces ouvertures là que lui joue ça
peut être un peu limite Stéphane c'est
compliqué hein parce que chaque
couverture c'est un peu bizarre souvent
mais il s'est approché quand même de
26,80 même avec ses ouvertures là qui ce
qui prouve la hauteur de son talent
comme ça j'avais joué à la dernière
ronde de Porticcio il y a quelques
années contre le grand maître
sans-goupta
donc il avait
pas loin de 2600
un peu moins il va être à 2590
et j'avais les blancs et j'avais fait un
mauvais tournoi j'avais enchaîné deux
défaites contre 21 à 50
enchaîné et après je te remonté en
battant de 2002
et au final dernière ronde ben juin 2006
en gros et si je gagne et ben je suis je
gagne quelques points
et puis du coup ben je joue enfin un
joueur vraiment fort et je suis content
j'avais les blancs
et puis avec les Blancs tu sais comme on
l'a dit l'autre jour on sent un peu
mieux quand même tu vois on est au lit
et puis ça dans la vie j'ai pas beaucoup
joué des joueurs à plus de 2006 tu vois
moi j'ai pas joué beaucoup le Top 12 et
puis j'ai pas l'occasion de jouer ce
jour-là et puis en Open pas forcément
toujours non plus donc en fait j'ai pas
toujours le l'occasion en fait ce genre
là donc j'étais content de jouer en 2006
et du coup je me suis levé le matin tôt
alors là la ronde elle était à 10h je me
suis levé hyper tôt pour me préparer et
ça je sens que ça va merdouiller un
moment non mais ça tu sais que moi le
matin je me lève pas le matin à 8h pour
me préparer généralement mais là je sais
pas j'étais chaud je t'ai motivé je
voulais au petit déj non rien manger
parce que je mange jamais enfin c'est
rare quand je mange un petit déj mais
donc je me suis un passage que j'ai
mangé
qui veut tous les détails et
c'est rien inside et moi je joue le jeu
je suis très très joueur aujourd'hui et
du coup en fait l'idée c'est que j'ai vu
sur E4
il jouait bon il jouait la Sicilienne il
joue la française et je me souviens
j'avais regardé sur sur la française il
jouait je crois 7 coups différents
c'est sur sur E4 alors je me suis un
plus mais sur e46 des 4 dessins moi je
joue les deux
et ici il jouait 7 coups différents
au troisième coup dans la française avec
les noirs et il avait plein de parties
dans chaque truc je dis vas-y quoi enfin
c'est chiant de réparer j'ai pas trop
réparer quoi et il joue aussi la
Sicilienne il joue à 4 5
et du coup j'ai ce que j'ai fait j'ai
pas préparé du coup 7 amis du coup j'ai
faim
j'ai pas regardé à chaque fois toutes
les lignes parce que j'ai pas que ça à
[ __ ] mais ce que j'ai fait en fait
c'est que j'arrivais mon répertoire il
dit bon où est-ce que je les trouve où
est-ce que je connais pas parce que si
et je regarde ça rapidement ma française
je dis bon c'est bon ça va j'ai regardé
mes sicilienne dis-moi c'est bon ça va
et du coup on a commencé une une
Sicilienne et ce qui est marrant en plus
c'est que je suis arrivé en retard à la
partie donc ça ça compte aussi en fait
on avait un gîte à peu près à 10 minutes
en voiture de la salle et vu qu'on était
plus que 5 et ben j'ai dû faire j'ai dû
faire aller-retour deux fois que ma
voiture parce que celui qui avait la
voiture donc j'amène un groupe
j'amène un groupe à la salle
voilà je reviens je prendrai et on part
à la salle je me gare et puis je vais
jouer quoi et du coup je suis arrivé à
la salle avec environ 10 minutes de
retard
et puis en plus vous savez ma partie
dessous cette tu as pris la plage tu as
aussi une piscine en fait tu joues dans
un centre de vacances donc j'avais
j'étais en maillot de bain en tong et
j'avais la serviette sur l'épaule quand
je suis allée de la partie donc le mec
il m'a vu arriver en retard en maillot
de bain tong et il s'est dit et mal
alors lui bah c'est le touriste quoi le
blog lui je vais le défoncer est-ce que
lui c'est pas c'est que moi je me suis
levé à 7 heures pour me préparer
et ça ça il le sait pas et tu vois il
voit le mec arrive on tombe short il
veut juste la partie j'étais préparé
comme un chien et il m'a joué une
variante imagine sicilienne avec eux 6
qui se transforme en fait que c'est une
sorte de taille manov avec G3 et en fait
on ajoute cette ligne là de la taille
manoeuf qui est extrêmement chaude donc
avec A6 et là il m'a joué H5 et donc H5
c'est nul qui se joue qui qui est
d'ailleurs souvent joué par les joueurs
qui veulent ils veulent gagner etc mais
c'est pas une ligne qui est complètement
dégueulasse c'est ça joue hein et mais
j'étais content qu'il le joue je me suis
dit ah il prend pour un JAMBON enfin ok
il a vu le touriste il veut me la coller
et en fait du coup bah j'ai Rocket j'ai
fait tout droit et en fait je l'ai
m'attends un coup
voilà
d'ailleurs la partie je traite de la
partie enfin je la commente dans une de
mes vidéos YouTube vous pouvez la voir
ça
et ben c'était marrant du coup parce que
c'était vraiment
bon pour le coup j'ai pas fait exprès de
faire enfin tu sais à la pas à la base
je voulais pas faire bluff parce que
juste ça la plage quoi c'était pas une
blague mais au final après coup quand
j'ai vu ce qu'il a fait et que j'ai vu
la partie technique de stouf maintenant
quand vous êtes bien préparé
tongs
d'ailleurs ça c'était une une histoire
parce qu'en fait si tu veux j'ai une
autre histoire encore une fois par
rapport à un bluff donc j'avais un bluff
de fou que j'avais passé un grand maître
il y a des années et quand j'avais
raconté cette histoire à l'époque a
remis de la Baca que tu connais et bah
il m'avait raconté une même histoire
après comme la mienne avec avec du coup
c'était bluff par rapport à une variante
que tu as préparé etc par contre lui son
histoire c'était un bel a même que la
mienne c'était un mixte il était arrivé
pareil avec avec tongs serviette pour
faire touriste et il arrivait à la
partie et à la partie il a fait genre
que réfléchissez pour voilà
le mec il tombe dans un prépa et quand
le mec tôt on s'en prépare mais il a
commencé à t'oublier de si elle défoncer
quoi et du coup c'était un peu la même
que moi sauf que bon moi dans cette
partie là j'étais pas vite fait j'étais
en tong et tout mais vu que j'avais la
piscine et c'était vrai par contre lui
je crois qu'il a fait exprès de les
mettre pour le pour le blog donc ça
c'est quand même quelque chose d'un
petit peu c'est au dessus quoi tu vois
bien sûr moi
c'est normal quoi
par contre moi j'ai pas voulu à la à la
à la base si tu veux quand j'ai quand
j'ai fait ça je voulais pas bluffer à la
base quand j'ai mis mes quand j'ai mis
mes tongs etc à la base voilà je voulais
juste je voulais juste ben une fois que
j'ai fini la partie je viens à la
piscine quoi je vais à la plage enfin
juste puis c'est pas du tout d'ailleurs
je suis à la plage
on l'a dit un battre un super grand
maître c'est difficile je sais pas sauf
moi je crois que j'en ai battu 5 dans ma
vie quoi depuis 2006 enfin vraiment
c'est
c'est pas facile quoi ah oui
plus de 2006 0
mais j'en ai non il avait un peu moins
de 2006 mais 25 en fait j'en ai battu
deux qui avaient un qui avait 25,90 et
l'autre qui avait
25-70 quoi tu vois
mais plus de 2006
j'ai jamais
battu je crois
je pars en partie officielle et parti
lente hein bien sûr bien sûr mais
ouais mais après
toute façon 26 c'est ça commence à être
le gap ou c'est vraiment difficile quoi
mais après j'en ai joué peu franchement
bon je sais pas pour ça que j'en ai pas
battu mais ça je crois plus 2006 en
partie non j'ai dû jouer corrobof qu'on
a parlé l'autre jour j'ai dû jouer il
sera discount à l'époque il avait 2006
et je n'arrive pas à me souvenir de Kyo
c'est plus jouer à plus 2006 pour te
dire
je peux en fait de jouer vraiment fort
quoi oui car
on parle on parle des parties lentes
quoi
parce que je pense qu'à part apparaîtra
DESCO et
et
je veux Christian Bauer une fois c'est
vrai que j'ai perdu mais c'était
peut-être j'aurais peut-être pu faire
mieux
mais
je sais plus qui j'ai plus de d'autres
j'en ai déjà une quarantaine moi donc du
coup ça c'est vrai que toi dès que tu
fais dès que tu fais un top 12 en fait
tu en joues déjà pas mal
ça dépend avec avec Guingamp à l'époque
oui avec mon équipe de Mulhouse
maintenant comme je traîne sur des
échiquets quand même un peu un peu plus
bas c'est plus difficile à part
Christian j'en ai pas joué cette année
tu vois c'est du coup
j'aurais vraiment beaucoup de joueurs
j'avais joué contre Freyssinet
au top 12 d'ailleurs j'avais perdu avec
les Noirs je l'avais bluffé d'ailleurs
c'était marrant
c'était marrant parce qu'en fait on joue
une ligne de la de la fille d'or donc
j'avais préparé un frigor à fond et en
fait il y avait juste une ligne hyper
rare que j'avais la flamme de regarder
parce que tu es hyper compliqué mais
c'était vraiment compliqué quoi cette
pause et du coup
j'ai j'avais zappé de la regarder et
puis après bah j'ai de bon je regarderai
votre maman mais bon on verra quoi et
puis je te promets que là je commence la
partie contre contre Laurent et là j'ai
eu un petit peu
pressentiment je me suis dit merde il va
me dire la lune que je que je connais
pas quoi je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
et il me joue exactement la ligne que je
savais que j'avais pas révisé que je
devais réviser mais j'avais oublié de
réviser tu vois il me jette mon la ligne
et du coup je savais qu'à un moment
donné il y avait un cavalier H5
nouveautés
et qu'après ça c'était un bordel sans
nom voilà il veut tout en prise
et
mais je connaissais jusqu'à cavalier H5
le cavalage 5 et du coup je me dis ça je
vais me faire défoncer quoi je connais
rien rien et en plus les coups sont
forcés dans cette ligne bref c'est assez
compliqué et du coup ben joue cavalier
H5 je le regarde dans les yeux je me
lève
[Rires]
il a joué j'ai fait le tempo déjà je me
suis levé quoi et là il est arrivé j'ai
10 minutes
et euh il venait en fait il venait de
faire cavalier F3 en gs5 si tu veux tu
vois et du coup moi j'ai fait du coup
cavalier H5 c'était le bon coup et là il
a réfléchi 10 minutes et il est revenu
en F3
quand vous faites peur à vos adversaires
des fois ça peut un peu sourire mais bon
en fait c'est chaud et du coup la ligne
que je enfin en fait si tu veux il avait
un peu la même ligne que moi on a on
avait la même analyse à peu près chacun
de son côté et il savait que c'était
très compliqué et il a eu peur de mon
niveau de préparation sur cette ligne
parce qu'en fait c'était le niveau zéro
voilà
d'où le bluff parce qu'en fait bien sûr
bien sûr si le sort ma ligne
d'ordinateur je vais jouer à 3500 hello
pendant 40 coups quoi tu vois le
problème c'est que lui il avait peur que
je joue à 3500 €, 140 coups il avait
peur de ça donc du coup il a changé il
s'est dit bah si je joue aux échec je
vais le battre il est nul tu vois et
c'est ce qu'il a fait il m'a battu et
puis voilà quand il y a pas de souci
il est modeste il est modeste non mais
mais mais c'est ça quoi et par lui il
avait 2700 € quasiment enfin qu'est-ce
que si je vous échecs qui t'a gagné quoi
donc juste il a décidé de pas jouer aux
échecs de pas jouer les grandes lignes
contre moi il a fait en arrière il a
besoin de chaque il m'a battu propre il
a rien à dire et
puis à la fin on a un peu on a un peu
analysé c'était intéressant parce que du
coup je dis je l'ai bluffé mais durant
[ __ ] il est de le savais il dit mais
en plus lui c'est lui qui c'est lui qui
l'a Éric pour le mariage qu'il avait
travaillé parce que cette ligne etc et
du coup pour le mariage après la partie
contre lui il avait montré il avait
pendant peut-être deux heures ils
avaient analysé la pollution de Paul
Mario ensemble et du coup il avait quand
même travail ça pendant deux heures avec
Paulo Mario tu vois donc c'est pas
n'importe quoi
et bref donc du coup non c'était marrant
en fait vraiment marrant cette anecdote
mais du coup je l'ai bluffé
la ligne de la ligne de la fille d'or
c'était quoi ce n'est plus je m'en
souviens de la ligne rapidement
très vite dans si je prends le côté noir
comment je peux t'en aller
F3
je pense
rock et puis à un moment donné il m'a
ajouté
et puis à un moment donné il y a du tout
j'avais fait du il y avait A4 d'abord
qui m'avait fait à 5 et là il a mangé là
il a mangé là je crois
et il m'a joué du c'était quoi la ligne
non excusez-moi il a fait fou à 3
donc c'est quoi la ligne
7 tours
parce qu'il y a une ligne avec prise
prise
et puis on prend puis on prend
je crois que c'est la ligne et dans
cette position le coup c'est 7 pour être
l'idée c'est que là si je fais cavalier
F6 bah il a d'un point des 8 et souvent
il y a ça en l'air aussi je crois que le
coup c'est Dame C7
et là il m'a joué du coup dame 2 je
crois il y a toujours
il y a aussi maintenant avant il y avait
les ventes avec H6 qui existait mais ça
ça marche plus à côté G4 et que j'ai 5
bref c'est une grande ligne je crois
qu'il m'a joué ça
et sur
5 c'est pas ça la nuit parce qu'il y
avait un cavalier H5 en fait d'accord
[Musique]
un tour de avant mais
en gros
mais c'est pas
c'est pas gagné
et sur cavalier F6 cavalier G5 et là
c'est ça et dans cette position du coup
c'est cavalage 5 sur le coup
parce qu'en fait la ligne si tu veux si
je fais un pas en plage 6 il me plante
qui avait les points F7
il prend B6
et dame C4 et j'ai perdu et du coup dans
la ligne en fait
dans la ligne du coup
il m'a joué le coup c'est cavalage 5
pour mener en fait de manger là des fois
je me lance du café des F4 aussi et sur
la ligne là ça marche plus parce que
maintenant
et donc voilà qui avait l'âge 5 qui
libère la colonne et c'était un truc
chaud quoi et je sais que sur cavalier
là j'ai encore oublié mais c'est une
ligne hyper chaude non mais c'est hyper
chaud et je crois que très souvent tout
en prise et plein de fois il y a du tout
assises qu'il faut au jeu pour défendre
là c'est hyper complexe et je me
souvenais plus de rien voilà mais
du coup du coup voilà j'ai fait j'ai
fait cavale HT tempo et je me suis levé
et il est revenu ici les joueurs qui
jouent vite dans les ouvertures on a
l'impression qu'ils connaissent tout et
ça fait vraiment peur quoi on rajoute
déjà ça si vous avez besoin de réfléchir
vous avez l'impression que lui connaît
tout parfaitement et que
c'était
durer
ça là j'ai dû faire ça j'ai dû faire ça
et ça et puis j'ai une position qui
était à peu près égale mais bon après il
m'a appelé quoi mais il recommence mais
tu vois le bluff en fait mais il est
revenu en arrière quoi et c'était
marrant quoi bref
bref bref bref
en tout cas oui dur de battre les les
2006 2007 je peux vous dire que il se
laisse pas faire autant faire nul c'est
tout à fait jouable comme on l'a dit
hier mais à partir de 2600 ça devient
dur de gagner et 2700 c'est encore un
autre monde d'ailleurs j'ai vu le petit
message de de paglobe pagloop qui parle
de des gens picoula à Belgrade et ben
picoula quand je l'ai joué
il avait
2547 ou 53 ou un truc comme ça
et je l'ai battu avec les Noirs j'ai
fait ma première dragon de toute ma vie
et je l'ai battu et Dragon du coup bah
oui parce que je l'ai battu avec c'était
cool mais j'étais pas bien je l'ai pas
je t'ai pas bien j'étais en souffrance
toute la partie et puis sprint tactique
en un coup à la fin il m'a donné une
pièce et quand j'ai pris la pièce et ben
il a tapé du poing sur la table
et en plus
il a parlé dans son dans en serbe quoi
il a tapé sur la table et je crois qu'il
allait me tuer pas assez tu vois c'est
le mec physiquement c'est un peu un
boucher tu vois et j'ai cru que j'allais
pas sortir de Serbie
j'allais pas j'allais pas j'allais pas
sortir
vivant de Serbie et du coup je l'ai
battu et voilà
oui alors Terminator on parle on parle
bien sûr des parties officielles des
parties lentes qui n'ont rien à voir
avec du Blitz qu'on peut faire sortir
comme
mais
oui du coup d'ailleurs Samy était avec
moi du coup à ce tournoi on avait on
avait on avait une belle est-ce qu'il
avait été performance amie juste ce que
tu as un souvenir de Batman intéressant
[Musique]
c'est vrai que j'ai gagné une partie que
j'aurais peut-être pas dû gagner mais
par rapport à Samy quand il me dit il me
dit que j'étais Sami il joue contre un
jeune qui était qui était malvoyant il
avait fait le championnat du monde des
malvoyants juste avant mais il avait
quoi il avait 12 ans et il avait 2200
hello ou un truc comme ça
[Musique]
et ils ont au moins ce petit échiquier
là pour essayer de se rappeler où sont
les pièces quand ils fatiguent c'est le
problème de la fatigue pour les
non-voyants c'est vraiment hyper intense
hyper énorme et on sait que c'est déjà
difficile le jeu mais dans ces
conditions-là bah c'est une grosse
performance vas-y souffle
voyons dans le même tournoi quoi 3 et
des jours à 2002 aveugle 2002
mais bon ok peu importe
tu vas voir mais il me semblait que ce
jeune était malheureux il me semblait
donc je me trompe peut-être de toute
façon c'est toi qui raconte l'histoire
donc on va dire que tu as raison voilà
donc j'ai raison et donc du coup bon on
peut importe le gamin il était au
tournoi ça a mis tu sais que c'est un
mini ouverture et il a il voit à peu
près 1000 points hello que ce qu'il a
sans offense je sais très bien c'est pas
du tout 5000 est très bons échecs mais
c'est mais les ouvertures c'est pas son
fort voilà disons-le
et du coup il jouait avec les Noirs E40
mais à l'époque il connaissait un petit
peu les ventes tu vois etc bon bref et
du coup il joue le jeune qui est qui
joue tout tempo le jeune a donc c'est
une Espagnole et donc je peux vous
montrer la partie
c'est une Espagnole Samuel et noir donc
je peux vous montrer de côté blanc c'est
pareil
c'est l'Espagne et Sami bon bah il
connaissait les lignes tu vois à peu
près normal sans connaître les coups
forcément en profondeur ni avoir
réveillé ses lignes Sami elle vient pas
de chaise basse limite
aujourd'hui quoi non c'était plus du
l'impro je pense par rapport à ça mais
au début il connaît mais après quand il
s'agit d'aller un peu plus loin bon bah
il connaît moins quoi mais le gamin il
avait un préparateur sur place
le gamin hyper bien préparé qui faisait
un super tournoi qui est battu de 2450
et du coup
donc ça commence comme ça donc là je
sais pas ça mieux ce qui joue à 6 ou
cavalier
peu importe on va dire assis cela peut
qu'il avait le cavalier F6 on en sait
rien
et puis en fait donc le gamin il joue
tout tempo genre
il va pas de question cou il va répondre
tempo et après il va je les deux coups
tu vois genre genre
sur E4 le gamin il joue dès que ça mit
il joue E5 le gamin avant de noter le
coup de E525
et ben il va d'abord je cavalier F3
tempo et après il va noter E5 et cavale
F3 vous voyez et du coup en fait et ben
donc on continue
et
assise donc ça a mis continue il fait ça
le mec il fait qu'avant
genre
un petit roc
et la famille
il joue avec son stylo dans la main il
écrit en même temps voilà il répète
comme ça tu avais la fin du côté et
jouer sans regarder le chéquier
et la famille elle est arrivée ou Sami
joue B5 et le gamin il joue ses trois
le gamin il a juste ces trois
et là quand il a vu que sa famille avait
gb5
tiens genre le
choc quoi ça
limite à pleurer quoi bon bah ça a mis
la manger le fou quoi merci
et du coup bon après on dit que je
chantais tu vois là ça a mis il me dit
ouais j'ai le pire appareillement j'ai
le noir contre le gamin qui connaît
enfin voilà etc et tout bah super tu as
gagné en cinq coups quoi bravo
même pas de prépa du coup c'était une
partie il y a une partie a gagné encore
il a dû confirmer à sa pièce en plus ok
bon
il a gagné il a gagné
quoi c'est scandaleux d'accord
avec les préparations théoriques maison
comme ça c'est bon c'est bon
franchement ouais ça va être belle quand
même
je pense que les Français sont pas comme
remarquer à ce moment
c'était
assez intéressant après il y a eu
d'autres bon il y a eu d'autres Français
quand on était là c'était vraiment un
tournoi où on regarde de beaux souvenirs
ça a mis il y a un Français qui était là
qui s'est fait il s'était fait mort par
un chien dehors
nos draps moi j'avais du sang sur mes
draps quand je suis arrivé
il y avait pas de l'électricité dans la
chambre la lumière a marché pas il y
avait de l'eau qui tombait enfin bref
c'était limite on pouvait mourir quoi
et
c'était très très bizarre très très
bizarre comme tournant franchement
ça ça dégoûte parce qu'il est tellement
précis sur l'échiquier Samy voilà qui
fait mal et du coup les joueurs en face
change d'activité très clairement après
c'était marrant tu vois franchement
c'était marrant
c'était marrant le tournoi il y avait en
fait quand tu sortais
ou il y avait une chambre dans la rue en
fait c'est tout ouf parce que
en face de l'hôtel bus et il y avait des
chiens errants à côté de bus et en fait
ils étaient hyper agressif ils étaient
mais toujours 5 ou 6 vraiment et tu es
là tu attends le bus et les chiens ben
ils vont vraiment tu as l'impression
qu'ils vont choquer dessus quoi t'as
l'impression que c'est et donc nous on
est toujours un peu peur quand vraiment
c'était chelou quoi
par le chien et en vrai tu te fais mal
tu te fais mordre par un chien errant
bon enfin
c'est chaud quoi je sais pas si le chien
il est malade quoi
il y a une partie en fait parce que tu
veux le tournage il se joue à au
brunoval ce qui était environ à 1h 1h30
de route de Belgrade et en fait il y
avait un bus qui était mis en place par
le tournoi pour amener les gens de
Belgrade jusqu'à Renova puis un moment
donné le bus c'est une accident il a eu
un accident de la route et du coup ben
donc moi j'avais mon adversaire qui
était là donc je pourrais plus jouer ma
partie tu vois mais les organes ont
décidé de décaler la ronde pour tout le
monde et du coup donc moi mon adversaire
en plus moi je vois je vois un ami à
2004 j'avais les blancs et moderne
et moi je dis bah non j'avais des blancs
même si j'avais 2002 qui avait 2004
et du coup on a attendu attendu et en
fait chaque demi-heure et ben on
descendait voir si le bus est arrivé en
remonter et puis bon voilà puis le bus
qui vient jamais quoi et au bout de deux
heures et demie à peu près et Ben et ben
au final tu as tu as le bus qui arrive
et ta français un des Français bah vu
que c'était mort un truc intéressant
qui est pas descendu pendant un moment
parce qu'il dit bon le bus il va encore
attendre etc et au final il arrive un
petit peu en retard et du coup il se
rend compte qu'il a perdu par forfait
tu vois il a perdu parce qu'il est pas
arrivé à l'heure ça fait trois heures
que j'attends le bus quoi et tu me
saoules quoi tu vois et le mec il arrive
il perd pas forfait quoi c'était et
vraiment le pauvre il a il lui arrive
tous les malheurs du monde à ce pauvre
français d'ailleurs c'est même plus
comment il s'appelait c'était un qui
s'est passé en
2011 je crois ou 2012
2012 je crois j'ai cru que ça allait
être gerto dans l'histoire non non c'est
un français qu'on connaissait pas qu'on
a rencontré sur place en fait
ok ok
bon est-ce qu'on après toutes ces bonnes
anecdotes est-ce qu'on se on se remet
dans dans cette dans cette ronde 8 du
tata une grande ou les joueurs sont
montés sur la table
mais bon oui puis un moment donné on est
on est au resto du tournoi la plus
partie de la ronde doit être bientôt
terminée du coup ouais c'est clair
maintenant juste pour finir on est on
est à l'hôtel du tournoi c'est et en
fait
toujours tel hôtel est toujours toujours
dans l'hôtel en fait tu es une salle on
arrive au resto et puis et puis moi je
mange une super soupe que franchement tu
étais pas la soupe tu vois et Sami il
arrive un petit peu après il dit bon du
coup qu'est-ce qu'on peut manger et donc
elle lui dit je vous conseille la fin
alors en entrée il y a une soupe mais
franchement je vous la conseille pas et
moi je suis comme ça en train de bouffer
la soupe elle était trop bonne en plus
tu vois déjà mais tu vois quand c'est le
serveur qui te dit qu'il faut pas manger
de la soupe
tu vois c'est que c'est compliqué et
toute la bouffe
mais peut-être poulet ou quoi enfin je
me souviens plus mais en fait tout il y
avait rien qui allait quoi c'était
rien qui allait quoi en plus à chaque
fois je mangeais la soupe de Sami je
mange la mienne
il mangeait du des chips dans 20 ans
en même temps ça devrait pas être dingue
non plus non c'était assez et puis à la
fin ça fait un peu escroc d'ailleurs ce
qu'on était invité
tous les deux Sami et moi et puis au
final il y a que moi qui me suis fait
inviter sa part bref il y a eu plein de
plein d'histoires
bon je vais effacer le commentaire de
famille dernier alors du coup
[Rires]
tournoi à refaire ah oui tous les jours
de
d'abducteur toi parce que du coup on va
on va voir comment ce qui s'est passé
ici
donc le café des B3 mais là j'ai vu un
Damien dame C3 là
je l'ai vu donc là
un petit peu mais encore une fois un
sûrement une idée qui là dans la
position donc c'est pas grave je
descends ouais donc je découvre qu'il
soit un petit peu comment dire inférieur
quand tu as une idée particulière etc
c'est pas grave parce que du coup les
noirs doivent trouver tous les coups et
c'est vraiment très dur il y a eu ces
cinq cavaliers G5 en fait on peut déjà
expliquer l'idée c'est d'enfermer le
foot 15 noire avec ce coup-là alors
c'est 5 et après on pique le foot 15
branche dans la foulée ok j'ai 5
et on va jouer une position sur le long
terme on va jouer bon fou en C1 qui va
pouvoir s'exprimer contre le fou des 6
et toute la stratégie de jeu d'abdosa
torov elle est basée là-dessus et c'est
déjà une position à ce niveau là de
résultats parce que on va la jouer sur
le long terme il y aura pas beaucoup de
complications mais petit à petit la
position d'arrognan
devrait être difficile ou alors à rognon
arrivera à survivre et à tirer son huit
point mais c'est une partie assez lente
où on fait souffrir l'adversaire c'est
les positions un petit peu de torture
sauf tourner pour gagner ouais c'est ça
donc
F4 et du coup F6 donc s'il prennent un
F4 il y avait aussi d'un projet 7 donc
c'était un peu tout qui s'ouvrait F6 ca
va les prendre le 6 dams et 4 et F5
maintenant il change les cavaliers et au
final dans cette position là ou en fait
les Blancs ont pour l'instant
toutes les cases blanches même si la F7
pour être possible éventuellement
échanger mais en fait sur long terme
vous voyez que j'ai un bon fou faut
qu'il ait la couleur inverse de mes
pions du coup mon fou il peut vraiment
manœuvrer facilement alors que du coup
alors que du coup le fou noir il est
très mauvais derrière cette pion là j'ai
une rupture ici une rupture ici une
rupture ici alors que les Noirs ils ont
beaucoup moins de rupture enfin en tout
cas c'est plus dur à faire la rupture
par exemple sur un G6 il y a toujours le
pion à F6 derrière qui peut être en
prise il y a le C4 qui peut aussi une
rupture mais ça va être très difficile à
faire vu la position des Noirs donc en
tout cas
en tout cas une pollution un peu de
pressing pour pour les pour les blancs
il y a eu à 5 ce qui donne du coup un
autre l'autre rupture avec B4
imposition donc une position où voilà
Abou peut pousser un petit peu sans
risque a priori il peut pas trop perdre
cette partie donc intéressant de voir
comment il s'y prend du coup soit j'ai
mon prono j'ai juste soit
ça me fait gagner un petit sable donc je
suis pas mal
tu avais pas bien dommage
va être bien bien prépa pour résister
alors la partie de saut contre Ding
rigolo alors on s'est arrêté ici donc F6
c'est un coup qui visuellement j'aime
pas du tout mais bon bah c'est sûrement
la théorie oui thématique on va dire
quand même pour exploser le centre
adverse mais ça fait peur parce que le
roi est derrière quoi c'est ça tu vois
que tu as pas encore sorti les pièces
donc ça fait visuellement ça fait peur
ça fait mais bon Ding c'est très bien ce
qu'il fait l'excellence C4 pédagogique
de wescasse tout le centre pendant que
tu étais
on met on met une belle pression il y a
eu un excellent coup après de westleso
sur le fou prend E5 fois F6 il avait
anticipé cette position sauf il a joué
cavalier des deux puisque le 5 est
protégé par une tactique en fait c'est
rigolo
et
je piquerai et du coup sur G6
d'apprendre on peut imaginer
d'investisse et sur le FC c'est ce que
je regarde
et ça c'est qu'elle dommage on laisse le
cavalier
l'échange parce que en plus il est
obligé d'échanger il a pas de coup
autrement et du coup tu ramènes ton
cavalier donc faites payer les échanges
quand un échange est forcé pour les deux
camps essayer de tirer profit de la
situation faire payer l'échange c'est
une notion très importante pour les
jours amateurs
gagner le temps quoi sur le change quoi
exactement donc belle partie aussi de de
soins ceux qui peut qui peut pour te
dire la vérité quand j'ai vu l'ouverture
j'avais presque envie de marquer un zéro
mais
[Musique]
parce que
oui
de prédire ce résultat bien sûr
non mais ouais j'ai essayé de pas me de
parader mais de toute façon j'aurais mis
nul
sans même enfin sans connaître la
position donc j'ai pas voulu t'entuber
et puis bon c'est même pas sûr du tout
qui va gagner non pas du tout pas du
tout mais la pression agréable en tout
cas belle idée de West slow
urgence c'était de sortir les pièces
maintenant il est pas loin de faire
quelque chose qui a mangé le pion à 6
contre Kemer moi j'avais dit quoi tu
avais dit à zéro comme moi ok ça
m'intéresse pas du coup
donc assez s'il y a que des deux petits
roc B4 cavalhc on s'est arrêté là
je suis
du coup à 4 il continue à prendre de
l'espace donc pour essayer de jouer
contre contre contre
F5 prise il faut manger sinon GR4 qui va
piquer le fond blanc
prise sous prendre dame 2 cavalier F6
comment
je sais pas trop ce qu'il a voulu
C4 pouvait peut-être dégager aussi un
moment et on pouvait avoir sur des trois
bouts j'ai mangé la peut-être voilà
chose comme ça B5 cavalière 5 B prend un
6 il a mangé assis et il a laissé
d'ailleurs la prise en 26
ok j'aime bien sacrifier des pions un
voyage
et puis on sait pas grave si j'ai
l'initiative il faut prendre un 6 et
promettre le cailland des 5 qui peut
rebondir en C3 ou F4
d'accord en
j'aurais pu faire ça aussi
à la place
mais
tout à fait
ce que tu dis là
étonnant de pas piqué le footcas blanche
d'accord bien d'accord
mon prise faut prendre du coup
cavalier F6
tours C1 on défend le pion et tout revit
[Musique]
ça peut déconner cela impose en tout cas
c'est un email pour une petite italienne
calme au départ ben le G5 cette variante
a mis un peu
le bazar sur l'échiquier et ça va être
une partie complète
alors rapport contre Prague
donc il y a eu un petit H4 H5 qui est
arrivé tu donc là vous voyez que le
rapport n'a pas ok
donc du coup on en est où il y a deux à
6 foubet 3 petits
ça existe
on va faire rebondir le cavalier B1 vers
l'aile roi ou vers les cases des 5 et F5
il peut aller en E3 ou G3 ce cavalier
donc les Noirs eux ce qu'ils font c'est
que ouais je sais pas mais tu vois au
niveau de la position les blancs qui
jouent vraiment à l'aile qui rendent pas
du coup la réaction de Prague elle est
quand même assez normal de jouer quand
même au centre tu vois donc sur une
prise ici et bon on aurait du coup le
centre et la colonne
et du coup ça me prend pas là avoir un
peu ce qui se passe sur un G3
qui était à regarder d'abord
[Musique]
c'est une grosse une grosse menace c'est
toujours la Bible qui a un fou ici ou
quoi ok donc elle va aller prendre les
deux c'est une grosse menace que je l'ai
pas vu
j'ai trois ou vous prend un F4 avoir
donc surjet 3 j'ai cavalu aussi sa
priori je pense
en tout cas oui c'est un pressing blanc
l'idée H4 H5 très fréquente sur les
cavaliers en G6 comme H14 avec un
cavalier en G3 qui est du grand
classique enfin Fabrice j'étais pas à 15
ans je suis arrivé à
je suis arrivé après
je suis arrivé après un an ou deux après
je sais plus est-ce que rapporte
à cet art dans le top dans le top niveau
moi j'ai connu Richard importe en
micropa Cup il était déjà très très fort
à 25 50 très jeune
donc faut regarder ça
il a été il a été bon jeune mais après
200700 il a un peu plus tardé peut-être
c'est un genre qui se faisait très peu
invité dans les gros tournois alors
qu'il avait 2700 pas tant que ça pas
tant que ça en fait il avait 2700 hello
je me souviens qu'il avait fait un pic à
27 50 à courbe plus il était redescendu
en 2007
et il faisait quasiment pas invité dans
les tournois et ça fait que maintenant
peut-être je dirais trois quatre ans
qu'il se fait inviter mais si tu
regardes un petit peu avant il se fait
pas trop invité c'est pas pour quoi du
coup mais
pourtant il a un style très
caractéristique mais
alors du coup van Forest est égalisé
c'est une partie qui nous intéresse la
particularité parce que tu as parié sur
un sur une victoire de vent forest
pendant que moi j'ai parié sur une huit
ans
donc si annule personne n'a gagné
donc du coup c'est tout
en 1996 donc il a 27 ans
et ça fait déjà 10 ans
qu'il est 2700 en 2013 je te dis il y a
environ il y a environ 5 ans
il commence à se faire inviter depuis
1700 à 17 ans bon vous voyez c'est il
était déjà très très fréquent voilà
donc ça on a vu et on s'est arrêté après
ici avec C6 donc il faut F4 standard
X3 F5
sont très forts acquis de 1903000 ça
accord jamais été fait on a un Magnus
hyper dominant
c'est c'est pas dire que ça arrive les
2903000 même sur cette génération ultra
doué personne très intéressante touche
très créa mais aussi c'est dur point qui
serait pas très content de ce genre de
coups parce que le roi blanc le roi noir
et les cases blanches autour du roi
un coup comme ça qu'on Dortmund lui-même
justement il m'avait dit là j'ai failli
tomber de ma chaise
c'est assez honnête avec ça mais j'ai
réussi quand même à l'embrouiller un
petit peu mais ça c'est marrant
rigolo donc là sur le long terme les
Noirs vise une attaque tout feu du roi
blanc mais sur le long terme il y a le
pion des 6 qui est très très faible donc
si on résiste à l'attaque
ça peut être dangereux cavalier B3 C5
par exemple là ça pourrait
faire mal la réaction au centre on a le
fouet fa qui pourrait tenir et roi achat
attention cavalier 3 les thèmes qui
pourraient peut-être
une partie une partie animée
un petit peu je crois que après c'est 5
on s'est arrêté
un pion isolé standard
et du coup on place les pièces
blanches
donc du coup qu'est-ce qu'on va voir
Kevin d'aller poser
alors j'ai fait mon mémoire d'entraîneur
dessus tout fait je disais se développer
bloquer pressé voilà donc c'est déjà la
base les petits trois choses à retenir
se développer bloquer pressé et ce que
j'aimerais c'est échanger tous les
pièces mineures aussi avec le camp qui
n'a pas le pion isolé pour pouvoir dans
une finale de pièces lourde attaquer le
pion isolé j'aimerais bien échanger deux
cavaliers et particulièrement le fou B6
aussi pour laisser à mon adversaire le
four à 5 j'aimerais bien en E6 le X5 à
la défense de son de son pion et moi un
fond un F3 avec toutes mes pièces
lourdes un triplement de pièces lourdes
sur la colonne des ça serait mon rêve
mais c'est bien dans ces positions long
terme il faut que je tourne gagner il
faut que j'améliore lentement d'avoir un
petit guide pour savoir quelle pièce est
changée et aussi comme tu le voulais
sauf savoir ce que l'on doit faire donc
se développer bloquer maintenant la
phase et ensuite presser et changer les
bonnes pièces on pourrait rajouter la
petite phase d'échanges des bonnes
pièces et on est on a tout le cahier des
charges à respecter voilà on a le manuel
c'est ça donc du coup l'idée l'idée en
fait c'est
de 1 bloqué le pion isolé donc
ce qui va faire plus tard si par exemple
le laisse c'est cavaler B5 pour venir
ici pour bloquer le pion difficile à
apparaît assis sur les cavaliers
échanger les pièces alors pourquoi
changer les pièces bah en fait
avec un pion isolé les noirs doivent
jouer actifs pour faire voilà leur fur
et isolé vous avez plein de positions où
on peut jouer volontairement avec un
plan isolé comme par exemple la lapine
qui est blanc c'est une ouverture dans
laquelle vous avez très souvent des
pions isolés et vous jette pour
l'attaque et du coup en fait il y a
plein de pollution on peut sur l'attaque
avec un pioneer mais du coup si vous
avez pas d'attaque et ben vous allez
être un peu passif et du coup votre pion
dessin va vraiment être une faiblesse au
cours de la partie donc là le but des
blancs c'est d'échanger des pièces parce
que plus ce sont des pièces moins les
Noirs pourront attaquer et plus de 5
sera faible en fait donc là du coup
cavaler B5 cavaler des 4 bah on va
échanger la cavalière ensemble l'autre
cavalier les fous et essayer de rester
avec une bonne pièce donc éventuellement
le fou B2 ou ça peut être aussi le four
F3 comme tu l'avancée qui attaqué le fou
ici contre du coup une mauvaise pièce
donc idéalement le foot case noire enfin
le foot casse blanche
mémoire qui serait en E6 donc voilà
après il faut d'échanger aussi
favorablement les pièces donc ne pas
échanger une bonne contre une mauvaise
là on voit bien que les cavaliers sont
pas mauvais le Fou est bon parce que
c'est le fou de l'inverse du pion
central et du coup un plan des Noirs ça
va être aussi plus tard de jouer des 4
dans les bonnes conditions pour échanger
ben ça pion isolé etc et la mauvaise
pièce et ben c'est le foot la couleur du
pion donc le four H5 donc du coup on
peut dire je pense à Kevin que quasiment
n'importe quelle pièce blanche contre ce
foulage 5 ce serait bien quand même
peu importe laquelle là franchement
c'est plutôt un mauvais pion isolé pour
les Noirs parce que
ils n'ont pas l'activité de pièces
suffisante pour compenser cette
faiblesse structurelle
donc je déteste sa position à Maxou de
l'eau aujourd'hui
je vais très facile cavalier A4 ou
cavalier B5 j'hésite entre les deux les
deux me plaisent les deux sont très bien
on va connaître les deux
adversaire bien sûr qu'on était et du
coup on a beaucoup alors je sais même
pas si je vais donner mon foin F6 mais
pourquoi pas en tout cas tu as raison en
tout cas on peut faire des menaces
touffes et
notre activité blanche alors qu'on n'a
pas de faiblesse structurel et peut-être
encore meilleur que les Noirs qui ont
concédé un affaiblissement pour pouvoir
avoir de l'activité donc les noirs sont
juste mal
je pense que le noir sont mal et en plus
une position qui peut clairement
[Musique]
sourire à
Google parce que franchement tu vois
c'est un organe qui est très technique
et du coup c'est une potion qui est
assez simple pour lui donc
j'aime beaucoup et je suis assez content
d'avoir parié
une victoire sur
sur Prague complètement et moi je me
suis dit bah vu sa forme du tournoi tu
vois ça va peut-être être un petit peu
dur c'était sur goûter si tu veux dire
il sort de partir 7h30 bien sûr il est
fatigué ok je suis
il est en quête de sa première victoire
jusque il a pas très bien joué mais bon
il a les blancs et voilà donc
favorable hier pour parram alors j'avais
tendance à croire que ça pourrait aller
et puis bon en même temps rien à faire
c'est juste que l'ouverture c'est pas
pas trop souri
apparemment
bon bah cool
dans la partie
et un petit le 5 dans la ligne regarde
dans l'esprit si on considère qu'on a la
pièce un peu mieux placée mais les
pièces noires
s'attendait entre guillemets à cette
réaction là
elles sont bien placées aussi quoi il y
a pas de problème
qui peuvent arriver aussi rapidement des
petites sacrifices éventuelles en prise
prise où est-ce qu'on met le cavalier
c'est un peu moche quand même le
cavalier en H7
on n'a pas beaucoup d'autres cases
il a pris des cartes
et donc là du coup on va voir sûrement
en cavalier H7 ça fait peur quand même
pour les
[Musique]
pour les pour les noirs
on voit que la courbe elle est toujours
bien poussée 6 à pousser si c'était la
pointe de Magnus trouver
trouver d'ailleurs très vite j'essaie de
voir où était l'embrouille puisque
c'était pas pour cavalier achat de
visiblement qui jouait cette position
alors bien sûr maintenant je gagne des
cases pour mon cavalier donc là la
première chose quand vous donnez une
pièce il faut regarder le sacrifice
évidemment là on va manger là
et du coup je vais bien se faire actives
etc et sur faut prendre maintenant que
la tour elle est devenue que par la dame
et ben on va tout simplement
chasser la dame
faut toujours surveiller les pièces non
protégées tactiquement même dans les
positions de stratégie
maintenant d'un point échec qui va les
capturer la tour et après l'échange donc
je sais pas trop mais on met les pièces
et ben c'est une position où je suis
beaucoup trop actif il y a à peu près
tout emprise est-ce qu'il aurait raté je
pense pas quand même il a juste cru
je sais pas bien non peut-être qu'il a
été
naïf il s'est dit bon il a raté ça c'est
fou c'est 6 c'est pas facile à avoir
vous voyez que Fabiano il a une position
maintenant que Magnus a mis son foncé
six le centre est fragile on le sent
sont des pions pendant et Magnus
récupère les cases E4 et des 5%
cavaliers il y a fubécate menace aussi
avec les Noirs donc il y a quand même
un jeu de pièces les pièces se
réveillent ici avec les Noirs il y a pas
mal de menaces
j'ai l'impression que vraiment après
le casque j'ai l'impression que les
Noirs commencent à être pas mal du tout
bien sûr tu as tout à fait raison
qu'avaler n'a pas trop de cases le fou
il a enfin par le fou
et ton centre et ben il est bloqué
5 prochainement des fous B4 des carrés
des 5
c'est pas bête du tout hein
C5 à un moment aussi pas mal non Fabian
est plutôt spéculer sur le fait que le
cavalier allait se retrouver en Hachette
je pense
il se pensait dominante trop dominant et
maintenant
ça peut être ça peut être vite
vite compliqué
pas mal de choses en l'air on a aussi
dame dessin qui a un coup candidat
mais bon il y a peut-être dame E2 ah non
dame de pas possible donc c'est quand
même pénible parce que
comment je fais pour défendre le bazar
peut-être il faut faire attention quand
même
pour eux
[Musique]
c'est pas si facile en fait
c'est pour ça que je vais faire plutôt
tout R2
mais du coup je vais acheter
sans la position s'effrite effectivement
les pièces noires s'activent d'un coup
merci à toi Benny pour le message
[Musique]
Kevin à parier sur une victoire guéri et
une victoire de vente Forest et que des
nuls
et moi
j'ai comme mais annoncé ça il a ajusté
après ces pronos pour faire 15 jours
et du coup la seule différence enfin les
seules différences que j'ai avec Kevin
c'est que moi j'ai parié non pas sur
vente forest mais sur erikasi et par
contre j'ai aussi parié sur google
tu es pas mal et Evan fofu et Erica
et là les blancs sont déjà beaucoup
mieux
mais il va l'envoyer à la maison donc
j'aime bien la position
de 5 G4 c'est vrai que faut pas faire
pas faire le malin peut-être des motifs
de cavalier 5 aussi
[Musique]
sacrifier ouvrir la case blanche peut
être intéressant à limiter ton fousser
vite si le fou c'est vite se réveille
dans ses positions là le roi blanc de
maths de temps en temps
ça avait été joué par par un gars ici
pour balancer G5 G4
auquel elle fait peur on va avoir des
belles parties en début les ouvertures
promettaient d'être un petit peu
soporifiques pour certaines parties en
fait
on en aura pas beaucoup
même la partie
casse encore aujourd'hui
et j'ai hâte de voir s'il arrive à
passer parce que j'ai envie de voir
techniquement comment on fait non qu'il
a obtenu bon fou contre mauvais fou ça
pourrait être intéressant
partie de goût caché hyper intéressant
pour vous pour le pion isolé qui se
retrouve dans plusieurs ouvertures donc
savoir manier le pion isolé c'est
important
et rapporte et Prague aussi ça ça peut
peut-être ça peut peut-être s'envoler
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va aller qu'est-ce
qu'on va aller voir maintenant tout au
fond
si vous avez des questions vous êtes
partis que vous voulez voir en
particulier
n'hésitez pas sur le chat à nous
solliciter vos questions
vous voulez voir des parties vraiment
n'hésitez pas de métal il veut voir
soading alors pas de métal hier c'était
pas là on a parlé de toi hier sur le
chat
pourquoi j'ai pas le temps
il est présent il est tellement présent
pas que s'il ne vient pas on le sait je
sais plus pourquoi on a parlé de toi
mais j'ai dit ton nom sur le chat et
puis on a il y avait quelqu'un qui est
venu sur le chat d'ailleurs qui a dit il
est où pas de métal
et après
et après quelqu'un peut-être de cette
d'ailleurs peut-être une Terminator
peut-être du coup
qui nous a écrit
je le connais il est où j'ai dit ben non
il est pas là je crois et en fait ben du
coup quelqu'un te connaissait sur le
chat
c'est ça c'est ça et
du coup et ben cette personne elle ne
trouvait pas
à toi
je te félicite maintenant essaie d'être
champion de France
aussi aux échecs c'est bien d'être fort
sur Internet c'est une grande qualité
c'est super mais après essayer de
progresser aussi en live
oui c'est clair que alors si tu ne joues
pas en live il faut le faire déjà très
clairement et si tu joues en live bah
voilà faut continuer tes efforts sur
Internet pour les valider sur
l'échiquier en réel
vu qu'on irait voir digne
on peut aller voir Ding alors juste
Abdou tu vois on a quand même à Royan
qui est qui a fini par faire G6 pour
casser un petit peu et essayer de
prendre lui-même aussi
un petit peu cette position le roi va
pouvoir venir ici
on se rapproche
ah oui tu avais mis ah oui tu avais
diminué aussi c'est vrai non je veux
sport Flammer je dis bon il a gagné quoi
du coup alors ça j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'il fait notre petit saut
B5 cavalage 6 donc
c'est pas bien mais là du coup il faut
sortir
et il a des cases de rebond donc c'est
pas trop grave votre cavalier quand il
va sur le côté s'il a des cases de
rebond ça va ouais
prise d'un prof fou d'être rock
B6 et j'aime bien
j'aime bien les les blancs Kevin on peut
imaginer plus tard un petit pressing sur
le pion isolé
c'est
c'est mieux pour les blancs c'est sûr
presque c'est encore compliqué comme
pose
les pièces noires sont intéressantes
ça me paraît moins avantageux que ce
cash contre parram un peu plus atypique
il va souffrir un petit peu quand même
aujourd'hui vraisemblablement mais c'est
pas encore c'est loin d'être
loin d'être fini
un petit plus
mais pas un gros plus
yes
il y a quand même des motifs encore de
prendre des seins que prend des 5 de
cavalier G4 de Cavalière vient en jeu et
ça va j'arrive à mettre au fond en B7 ça
va aussi enfin bref il y a plusieurs
configs de pièces qui sont intéressantes
pour pour les noirs
évidemment la position
la position blanche et structurellement
et sur le long terme plus agréable
alors du coup
guérialisme on dit qu'il y avait plein
d'échanges est-ce que c'est-il passé
c'était hyper vite en plus
tu vois les F4 prend
[Musique]
trop vite
qui peut arriver à tout moment pour
ouvrir ses fous
et
compliqué il y a un pion de plus mais
on va pas pour l'instant
ouais le gagnant du tournoi se dessinait
JL ben si on suit les résultats actuels
il y a un abdos à torov qui est très
dominant puisqu'il a un point d'avance
maintenant on peut pas encore confirmer
qu'il va gagner le tournoi mais il a
pris une petite option on dit une petite
option SI Carlsen avait un score comme
celui-là on dirait il a pris une grosse
option simplement d'où ça t'auras n'a
pas n'a pas encore
le même CV que Carlson par contre c'est
un des meilleurs joueurs jeunes de la
planète et là il gagne 23 points et
l'eau il est absolument monstrueux
jusqu'à présent on va voir s'il va tenir
jusqu'au bout si tient jusqu'au bout à
ce niveau là il gagnera le tournoi
rapport alors rapport contre Prague donc
on s'est arrêté au petit cavalier au
petit cavalier ici il a donné le pion G2
5 t'es pas tu es pas l'un des meilleurs
jeunes de la planète aux échecs mais sur
plein de registres sans doute et puis
des plus si je donne chez 525
mais si tu le prends
je peux triper avec un roi F1 pour pour
ouvrir la colonne g de mater
ouais tu voulais prendre un F4 tout de
suite de ton pouvoir
je pensais que tu voulais jouer ton
petit cache pour faire mal de tout à
l'heure
et essayer de travailler sur ce sur ce
clouage
[Musique]
là en fait hier je gagne direct non
ça c'est malin un peu tout match
regardez dans l'idée si il prend ben je
prends là
et du coup il bouge le roi et après
manger ici quoi voilà j'ai éliminé le
défenseur du mais bon après ce qu'il
veut la faire propre je fais juste ça ça
et peut-être encore plus fort en tagline
quoi
j'ai juste une idée mais juste au moment
où donc
madame
affiche mais c'est mieux de faire quoi
je crois
avec des perspectives très intéressantes
en pratique je préfère jouer côté noir
il y a beaucoup de pièces donc on aurait
gagné la pièce tranquille donc après là
vous voyez un truc important c'est
qu'une dame ça vaut 9 points et que là
dans la position et ben les Noirs ils
ont deux fous et un cavalier pour la
dame donc 3 6 9 en fait du coup ça se
voit pas compter ah non j'ai une dame de
moi non compter les points que vous
donnez pour la dame quoi et c'est pareil
pour la tour qui vaut 5 points mais
c'est moins j'ai une pièce donc un
cavalier et genre de pions bah ça fait
trois peu de 5 donc c'est pas grave vous
voyez donc essayez de bien compter le
matériel que vous mangez à chaque fois
et parce que des fois on l'oublie un peu
et on pense qu'on a une dame de moins
etc c'est pas vrai quoi
ok donc tout prévu j'ai trois
c'est bon
tu peux pas prendre G2
c'est très intéressant après ce que je
peux pas jouer j'ai une question sous
parce que je pourrais jouer un petit
Ashes dans cette position pour gagner le
foot de 15 noir
6 alors faut H4 c'est une option en
disant que je peux me faire faut prendre
un vrai bien vu bien vu la petite
tactique
toi tu es malin
[Rires]
on a un Kevin très mesquin
je joue dans le registre de ce stouf
maintenant je commence à m'habituer tu
vois
ça y est on connaît un peu le personnage
maintenant
je sais pas si trop ce qu'il a prévu sur
archi
un F4 c'est pas forcément ce qu'on veut
là on va ouvrir la colonne eux sur le
roi donc tous les vis-à-vis qui vont
arriver comme ça
manger F6 ben j'étais un point F6 on n'a
pas forcément envie de donner le CASE
noir la dame noire qui va s'activer
et four H4 comme tu l'as dit il y a ça
ça en fait
de donner le pion G2 souffre mais je
crois que c'est une erreur après H6
parce que je gagne le coup
logique et maintenant
[Musique]
c'est très difficile
ces anglaises
[Musique]
Jules Jules pas assez fort on a déjà
répondu
mvl pas invité pas envie et et Filou ben
il avait eu un
on va dire
une petite embroue il y a quelques il y
a deux ans je crois avec les
organisateurs et du coup depuis il a
plus envie de participer
voilà pourquoi je suis pas autant de moi
ils m'ont pas invité figure-toi c'est
abusé
c'est un peu abusé quoi c'est un peu
c'est complètement hallucinant mais
d'ailleurs avant c'est pas grave
tu t'es déjà engagé sur les commentaires
de moi j'avais dit non je commente non
mais viens jouer non ça va quoi et puis
tu vois c'est un peu comme ça tu vois un
peu Masters du monde non pas pas
intéressantes donc du coup pourtant il
voulait mais
au final il m'avait dit non au début
après il me disait oui derrière je dis
bah non quoi pas dire ouais d'accord
dans le challenger on va passer on avait
eu Marc-André mauriti ça aurait été
intéressant de le voir le voir aussi
dans ce tournoi là après je pense qu'il
tourne un petit peu au début il a joué
l'année dernière il y a deux ans
et puis bah oui donc je pense qu'il
tourne complètement il tourne
complètement il va laisser faire venir
un max de joueurs possibles
donc on va dire c'est ils prennent les
14 15 ans dans le challenger et quand
vous avez 17 18 ans et que vous avez
percé vous allez dans le a
donc la moustache disparaîtra demain
salut poignard
je sors à la moustache
maintenant on a envie de jouer des
schémas à base de dessin pour vrai mais
il y a encore le 5 et 4
alors comment on fait là c'est le grand
moment de la position
des 5 j'ai trouvé E5 je souffle avec la
foulée
et du coup j'aimerais faire des sacs
mais comment je fais sur 5
vous fait le créer à fond mais j'ai pas
beaucoup de monde pour ramener à la fête
[Musique]
un coup aussi un peu créa c'est cavalier
G4 directement
pour provoquer des quatre et après
essayer de travailler sur le pion E4 ce
qui est pas si facile que cela à
défendre
il y a quand même des cartes qui
arrivent pas facile
ou alors je me venge
sur le pion h avec fuj4 mais 4 protège
le pion H5 mais si je fais des 5 sachant
que de toute façon moi je vais regarder
l'idée de vous prendre F2 qui a l'air un
petit peu tout match
je monte juste donc là
[Musique]
mais bon
et plus précis et du coup si je fais des
cinq je provoquais 5 peut-être
maintenant manger Jeff 2
et c'est un peu cher
c'est un peu cher j'ai pas j'ai pas
assez très fragile en plus donc on va
juste passer
donc
ouais j'ai juste pour l'instant trouver
une seule idée sauf c'est quel G4 pour
mettre pression sur carte provoquer des
cartes et mettre pression sur le 4
j'ai réussi à ouvrir les lignes donc là
jusqu'à que les deux
F6 ouais c'est ça c'était ça l'idée
c'est assez rigolo d'ailleurs de faire
que j'ai 4 kf6 c'est pas courant
qui fait le 5 je peux encore
refaire kg 4 ou prendre et refaire kg 4
il y avait dame B1 qui me questionnait
en fait ici c'est je me suis arrêté à
Damme bien mais en fait il y a dame set
que j'ai oublié tout à l'heure
OK et on va vraiment réussir à ouvrir la
pose
donc oui c'est ça le schéma c'est pas
facile à trouver quand même autant le
premier coup de jouer à chier je
trouvais ça assez facile autant il faut
trouver une belle manoeuvre parce que si
vous voulez c'est pas naturel de faire
kg 4 de se prendre des cartes pour
ramener le cavalier en F6 c'est beau
quand même
c'est vrai que là là
visuellement tu dis bon ben si il me
fait ça je fais ça ça je ferme tout et
je vais manger là et si il fait rien il
va perdre le premier 4 quoi et on nous
annonce une gaffe apparemment il y a pas
de métal et Marie qui se rejoignent pour
dire gave de Fabiano oula camsen prend
le dessus et il y a eu quelque chose il
y a eu fou ces deux c'était le coup de
connecte et en hiver clairement on
l'appelle maintenant le Mozart des
échecs car le scène avec sa coupe on est
d'accord
alors car voilà qui a une demi-heure de
retard à la pendule
j'ai parié hier avec toi qui reviendrait
pas dans le podium
mais là il est en train peut-être de
l'aider
parce que s'il y a quelque chose m'amuse
à voir alors tous ces deux
je comprends on avait des histoires de
Dame des 5 maintenant la gaffe on la
voit pas encore si facilement que ça
c'est quoi la gaffe dame dessin
qu'est-ce que je peux jouer sur Dame des
cinq on qu'est-ce qu'on joue au stuff
on était pas sûr
est-ce qu'on avait regardé fou ces deux
là oui
ça ça en fait tu peux te dire que
c'est vraiment pénible déjà
genre ça
sans dire en fait que du coup il peut il
ajoute un dessin d'ailleurs sur ça du
coup s'il prend là je prends là et après
du coup
je voulais pour venir ici j'avais pas
donc on avait parlé tout à l'heure Dame
des cinq tours 2 et là il y a beaucoup
de cours très intéressant
on voit que les pièces blanches sont des
coordonnées chez noir il y a pas
beaucoup de choses qui sont non
protégées on comprend le foussaissiste
la Dame des saints qui a pas une pièce
qu'on comprend pas ici le fouget3 il est
non protégé la tour 2 elle est bizarre
le Cavalia 3 hyper bizarre la tour a un
non développé la dame D1 sur sa case
initiale c'est pour ça que la position
ne va pas à ce point là maintenant
j'aimerais bien qu'on trouve le coup
décisif
on a plusieurs options
que
Fabi a raté ça
j'ai vraiment l'impression parce que tu
vois ils ont joué la variante tu vois F4
E5
prise
10 minutes
on peut le remonter sur la prise
et ben on fait ça justement
ça marcherait pas parce que j'aurais
soit ça soit même peut-être même dans
trois là donc mais l'idée en fait on va
d'abord éliminer la tour
gratuit donc du coup je tape là et là et
puis bon bah je les pièces très active
en plus
sur maintenant je vais manger ici
et après la prise et ben du coup la tour
reste pas défendu
il est en train avec les pièces blanches
de faire un peu la fatigue quoi tu sens
un peu la fatigue en fait si tu veux de
dire du contrecoup de la partie qui a
duré 7h30
et du coup ton BK
[Musique]
pression énorme puisque les menaces sont
toujours là toutes les pièces sont
actives on parlait de coordination des
pièces on voit que là c'est multimonas
et c'est joué très très rapidement
5% de précision deux coups brillants
fous si c'est trop B4 après là il
récolte il récolte vraiment ce que lui
donne Fabiano qui va sans nous perdre
dans les cinq prochains coups
limite là ça abandon en fait
de Fabiano ou une séquence ratée pour
être tout à fait précis depuis son E5 en
fait qui n'allait pas un père dans 23
coups avec les Blancs
Caravana enfin c'est
[Musique]
quand même c'est rarissime mais c'est
hyper étonnant quoi
s'il te plaît souffre pour revoir la
séquence que il avait quand même bien
géré son début il était un petit peu
mieux dans cette position légèrement et
il a tenté de se lancer à la bardage de
la position noire avec F4
trop ambitieux
peut-être que tu pouvais à la limite le
jouer mais qu'il fallait consolider
derrière sur cavalier C6 je sais pas par
quel coup
peut-être même cavalier C4 mais il y a
toi des dessins encore ou des cavaliers
prend 4 et du coup il faut consolider
par Dame des trois ou dame F3 mais il y
a le pion à 5 en lettres qui doit juste
avant de se F4 améliorer quoi
deux Dame des deux tourner un
et essayer de tu vois et après tu vois
ce qui se passe quoi je sais pas
exactement en tout cas sa position à ce
moment-là était tout à fait jouable et
même plus que je vois pour moi c'est
petit avantage blanc position un peu
plus agréable à jouer
et même son F4 me choque pas tout à fait
mais en fait c'est pas encore de 5
peut-être que c'est pas obligé de le
faire maintenant mais et puis Méline
nous dit plus de 5 c'est vrai que F4 est
fulh H4 ça empêche l'adversaire de
bouffer E4 et c'est vrai que c'est
encore non plus dans l'idée aussi là on
voit que c'est plus qui est bien mieux
que ça qu'on retrouve Carl voilà c'est
j'ai le Cox bah en fait oui et non parce
que il a fait une partie bah écoute
c'est normal à son niveau au début grâce
à la préparation d'ouverture grâce aussi
à ses connaissances etc et à sa
compréhension mais là c'est surtout une
gaffe de carvana parce que en fait quand
on voit la partie
5 en fait
au final c'est mal joué quoi tu vois
c'est une gaffe en fait au final ça
parce qu'après ça ça
est fou c'est 6 qui est d'ailleurs a été
raté par par Fabiano ben les blancs sont
beaucoup mieux quoi enfin les noirs sont
mieux avec Dame dessin qui arrive etc et
après il faut que je précise mais tu
vois on voit bien qu'ici il a été
surpris Fabian et là je foutais mais du
coup c'est plutôt une grosse gaffe de
Caravana qui qui va du coup amener enfin
donner la victoire à gratte-ciel donc
c'est car ça n'a bien a bien joué bien
sûr mais c'est pas vraiment lui qui a
c'est pas une grosse partie comme il
aurait pu faire pour que d'autres
joueurs exactement là c'est plus une
carte
il a juste joué des coups normaux quoi
voilà donc c'est pas c'est pas une
partie on va dire on peut pas dire à
cette partie que c'est le que c'est
le retour de du carrassen qu'on connaît
je suis pas d'accord à ce niveau là
tous les temps à titre perso il y a eu
d'autres très grands joueurs il a
bénéficié d'avoir
[Musique]
les avancées technologiques mais comme
tous les autres joueurs modernes donc
pour moi il est il est au dessus de tous
vu sa domination là depuis les 10
dernières années
preuve en est pour qu'il ait l'idée de
refuser de défendre son titre c'est
vraiment qu'il est
ultra ultra dominant
et oui de risque pas mal c'est marrant
pour le 5 mais je parlais vraiment de
son E5 à lui et mais nos mots on est
obligé de jouer l'espagnol avec les
Blancs quasiment sur 4 5 à entrer au
niveau pour prendre l'avantage ou
l'italier n mais on ne peut pas se
priver d'une arme comme l'espagnol même
s'il est vrai que Carlson Excel dans
celle-ci
car wanna normalement n'est pas
maladroit par contre comme on constate
tous aujourd'hui il est passé à côté
salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent en
tout cas voilà bah on voit
oui il a jamais joué il a jamais joué
contre Fisher ça c'est ça c'est sûr mais
en terme de régularité à haut niveau et
de densité aussi de très très forts
joueurs
il est quand même assez exceptionnel
oui les joueurs n'ont jamais joué entre
eux enfin tu vois jamais jouer ne pourra
jamais jouer contre les capables locales
et à l'équine les Fisher les casse pas
en fait je sais pas chacun vraiment
étant avec eux dans son temps c'est un
peu dur de comparer on peut pas affirmer
avec certitude mais chacun a ses avis et
moi je suis pas contre de dire Carlson
on va être moi ben pour moi il y en a
trois mes trois grands
favoriseur Castorama fait 45
et j'arrive pas à les différencer donc
moi j'ai pas d'avis là dessus mais après
bon ben
plus jeune fort et en fait depuis 10 ans
il est ouais
par exemple il était pas suivi par une
arme grand-mère
il avait pas toutes les ordis et tous
les stocks fiches tous les Cloud et tous
les tous les les le matos pour
travailler que ont maintenant les
joueurs d'aujourd'hui
est quand même très importante il y a
une densité de super joueur qui ont
accès aussi aux informations et les
jeunes qui arrivent sont très forts
pour l'instant des petits guilis
seulement et le dégomme pas facilement
c'est ça donc en fait voilà
c'est vrai que il a accès à tout mais
malgré tout et ben il est massacre enfin
c'est le numéro 1 contesté malgré tout
ces informations qu'il y a de partout
donc ça montre quand même donc voilà en
fait on peut avoir si on veut des
théories etc il y aura jamais de preuve
on pourra jamais prouver vraiment quoi
que ce soit mais après la question
qu'elle m'intéressante et puis c'est
cool aussi de se poser des questions là
mais oui non je pense que c'est c'est ça
nourrit un débat ça nous regarde
[Musique]
quoi que ce soit dans tous les cas les
trois ont été
les meilleurs joueurs de l'histoire à
mon à mon sens et surtout pour la
théorie et Magnus ça a beaucoup plus
d'éléments que
[Musique]
que que les autres
joueurs puisque Kasparov et Fisher c'est
encore pire et non pas bénéficier des
avancées informatiques colossales
donc du coup clairement ça aurait été ça
aurait été marrant d'avoir
du coup toute la génération de Fisher
Karpov etc
avec du coup toutes les
toutes les tous les modules qu'on a
maintenant etc tu vois et avoir un peu
comment il se débrouille c'est vrai que
ça aurait été marrant mais parce que bon
encore une fois on sait pas mais
voilà
ok
Kevin est-ce que tu veux construire une
petite pause il me semble que tu as une
cuisine à ranger
[Rires]
quelle balance mais c'est pas faux c'est
pas faux tu rangement rapide et
je serais bien pour repartir yes on va
faire une petite pause de vraiment 5
minutes et puis on se retrouve juste
après donc restez parmi nous et puis et
puis à tout de suite
bon allez à tout de suite yes
[Musique]
et on est de retour avec avec Kevin plus
pour très longtemps peut-être Kevin mais
mais
mais du coup on a vu que Carlsen du coup
a quasiment gagné sa partie
pour le pauvre Fabiana Kawana parce que
faire ça avec les Blancs je pense que
c'est un plaisir c'est une tension mais
c'est un plaisir aussi de jouer contre
Magnus et il a envie de montrer son
meilleur visage dans ce tournoi pour
l'instant c'était tout à fait correct il
aurait pu battre par Amir sur la fin de
partie et là aujourd'hui bah il va
perdre
de manière
hyper rapide contre Magnus
il est ouais là il est dans plus que
dans les cordes aucune pièce active
il faut juste terminer proprement
mais j'ai un pion non plus niveau
matériel et toutes les pièces noires
sont très actives contrairement aux
pieds blanche tour des deux c'est est-ce
que c'est jouable tour des deux ou
est-ce qu'il y a encore fou B3
à voir mais regarde tout reprend un deux
ce serait pas ça serait pas stupide hein
l'idée que disait si Kevin c'est que sur
ça ça et ben déjà je contrôle la Casa de
à tout reprend un deux c'est peut-être
hyper fort
ouais on va regarder je vous prends ici
ça a l'air tour à deux c'est contrôlé
donc on peut pas le jouer voilà il faut
jouer roi j'ai un roi F1 il faut
défendre comme ça ou alors faire des
fins mais bon qui donnerait la dame quoi
je peux continuer avec cavalier H5 à
faire mal c'est ça mais du coup sur sur
tous les trois mais j'étais un projet de
qui va mettre fin à la partie
un moulinet en plus on va passer bien
pour vous le moulinet
et maintenant on va aller par ici et
s'il y avait eu plein de trucs à bouffer
on aurait pu se régaler hein
complètement c'est ça qu'on appelle le
moulinet on reproduit ce schéma là
plusieurs fois c'est super sympa alors
question Kevin c'est quoi le meilleur
coup ici
tu peux te dire bon tu vas gagner sur
ton reprend cavalier mais il va y avoir
de cavaler prend du coup je pensais mais
c'est à faire [ __ ]
je te laisse dans ton
dans ton truc tu peux pas vraiment
empêcher enlever ça et si tu manges
cette fois-ci je la mange gratos tu vois
en fait c'est juste un cauchemar
on peut jouer cavalier H5 est fou c'est
5 ça doit ma tête quasiment sûr mais bon
de toute façon c'est la régalade cette
position
donc tourner deux
et en plus le pire c'est qu'il va se
prendre en plus une fin hyper esthétique
kerwana contre lui-même du coup ça va
être et oui Annie de je suis bien
d'accord avec toi ça va être la violence
franchement la moulinette de l'amour
ouais Frot c'est pas mal dit et surtout
ouais bah Fabiano il va être il va être
bien de quoi
que déjà la partie
quasiment parfaite pour Magnus et en
plus avec le prix de beauté derrière
mais bon du cavalage 5 j'ai même tout
reprendre le sein peut-être un endroit
la pression elle augmente hein
je veux manger ici non je pense que
c'est un moment donné
grosse partie en tout cas
après là il a vraiment eu du bol parce
que
enfin si vous voulez il a pas provoqué
la réussite qu'il a c'est vraiment
Fabiano qui a lancé un truc au centre
sans maîtriser et en oubliant quand même
l'erreur foussaississe elle est assez
grossière de d'oublier ça et derrière en
plus il a fait une connerie qu'il achève
direct
il a joué
normalement l'ouverture
et il bénéficie d'une erreur d'une
séquence abominable
au 18e 19e quoi
et donc Magnus il a pas continué par par
tour des deux qu'il a forcément vu mais
il a considéré que cavalier 4 c'était
abandon aussi voilà pourquoi il a pas
joué
il se passe quoi
du coup
ouais ça serait bon ça serait toujours
mieux mais c'est pas la même non il a dû
là je peux attendre un petit peu ah non
pas vraiment et avant
c'était quoi
ah oui donc en fait ça va durer encore
longtemps donc
je mette l'ordi voir juste
ce qui s'est passé parce que je crois
que
beaucoup plus fort en plus ça se sentait
[Musique]
parce qu'en plus ça se regarde c'est une
fille de forcée donc et ça c'est un peu
moins fort
mais après
la finale complètement foutu paire de
fou et puis alors que moi ça m'aurait
saoulé de jouer cette position mais lui
il se dit bon
en fait si vous voulez oui on est
content avec les Noirs mais bon il y a
encore du travail
et ce qui est pas faux en pratiquant
c'est la part de fou j'ai la meilleure
pièce tu as le pion G2 enfin bref
ouais ok bon ben je pense que personne
qui va finir il y a une partie 4
terminée on a une partie terminée
donc on avait tout à l'heure parlé de ce
bon fou contre le mauvais fou mais du
coup à rien elle va réussir à jouer du
coup bah le coup G5
pour fermer la position et sur la
prévoir à partir du 19e sauf ou du 17e
là on s'est arrêté là je pensais qu'il
allait quand même lui faire mal je
pensais aussi un peu donc
là
garder les pièces donc le roi qui vient
le 7 le roi des roquet mais c'est pas
grave dans cette position il peut rien
se passer il y a qu'une seule dame qui
se balade donc c'est pas grave tout F3
ama 8
il a essayé de la jouer un peu vu qu'il
a aucun risque
mais enfin peut-être que la position à
l'industrie
apparemment ce que l'ordi préconise
avant de jouer tour F3 pour pouvoir
faire G5 avant directement après
l'échange de dames
c'était hyper malin
c'est à dire sur ça
voilà
éventuellement on joue pour G5 assez
rapidement peut-être à la cache 4 je
sais pas mais j'ai cinq directs même et
peut-être qu'il pouvait essayer quelque
chose
j'ai pas vu
ils ont fini par échanger des pièces
et en fait la position ben il y a pas
grand chose au final
il y a pas grand chose au final
les blancs vont rien faire n'en vont
rien faire et c'est égal donc pour
l'instant ça fait un bon résultat chacun
Kevin
[Musique]
et
alors du coup olive moi les ordis
ils ont
ils ont révolutionné les ouvertures et
là ils ont un peu cassé le jeu au niveau
de des ouvertures qui sont tellement
précis qu'il y a beaucoup de nuls à
cause des ordis par contre
et donc on peut plus jouer de Gambie on
peut plus jouer d'ouverture de nous deux
ben on a parlé de Christian Bauer
typiquement à très haut niveau c'est
quand même de plus en plus difficile de
jouer dans ce registre un petit peu
changeant mais avec des ouvertures
réputées un petit peu douteuses par
contre ils ont amélioré aussi un sens
dynamique beaucoup plus
profond avec des sacrifices d'options
très calculatoires donc ils ont fait
avancer le jeu énormément aussi dans
dans le fait d'être de moins en moins
matérialiste
finalement des joueurs comme va chez
Lagrave très créatif avec des sacrifices
de pions tout le temps
ils ont été aidés je pense par le modèle
de l'ordinateur
donc il y a un avantage inconvénients si
tu veux il faut y faire attention aux
ordis alors utilisation pour pour les
joueurs amateurs très clairement on voit
trop d'amateurs faire confiance à l'ordi
leur dit à toujours raison mais il
explique pas pourquoi et ça c'est un
gros problème donc des fois on ressent
pas les problèmes pratiques d'une
position et quand on y est confronté
après sur l'échiquier ça fait tout drôle
donc attention de rester critique quand
même
mais on peut regretter quand même la fin
spectaculaire que pouvait avoir cette
partie après karwin est en train de
défendre à la main parce qu'il sait
qu'il est complètement foutu donc il
voit pas trop d'intérêt il pourrait
abandonner très prochainement
moi je pense pas Mollo je pense qu'il a
juste
simplifié la position où il a un pion de
plus paire de fou colonne ouverte et un
gros problème sur le pion G2 et du coup
ce qui va se passer c'est que le
cavalier parce que moi je finis le
cavalier le four
et en gros là je me lave fou des cinq et
quand cavalier bouge et ben j'ai tourné
deux qui va taper là dessus et même si
les gens viennent défendre avec la tour
ici je peux avoir un fou C5 qui vient
bouger la tour ou même du fubécatement
en fait
la pollution molo je pense que juste
elle est elle est perdue mais puissance
1000 quoi donc
à ce niveau là en fait il a juste pas
voulu se prendre la tête c'est du bâtir
là c'est sûr que c'est gagné à plus de
pièces et plus rien faire
mais en fait car ça est tellement plus
fort que nous que en fait pour aller
beaucoup plus claire en fait tu vois
dans l'idée mais
c'est clair que que tour des deux bah
oui nous on voit cette pollution on se
dit bon ok j'ai raté quoi parce que on
voit qu'on a qu'un conclus c'est
peut-être blanche des gotte un petit peu
et donc du coup on va peut-être plutôt
regarder deux mais lui il voit que cette
position elle est complètement finie
donc du coup et bah juste il a
il
simplifie quoi et je pense que c'est
très très technique en fait Carlson et
sur tous les critères de stratégie la
position blanche fait défaillante le
même la sécurité des rois comme comme il
y a la rentrée de la tour en deuxième
c'est dangereux ensuite au niveau du
rapport matériel on a pion moins plus
paire de fous de moi donc là on est déjà
peut-être moins 2 activités des pièces
c'est les pièces blanches sont 0 et les
fous hyper intéressants les fous noirs -
3 et la structure de pions et puis on
passait comme purée isoler donc moi
quatre quoi enfin je veux dire cette
position elle est dégueu quoi et tous
les signaux de jugement d'une position
sont au vert pour les Noirs voilà donc à
voter
du coup pour l'analyse de l'hiver ben je
pense que c'est beaucoup mieux de enfin
en tout cas c'est plus efficace
d'analyser avec un entraîneur avec un
gui qui sait lire l'ordinateur parce que
l'ordinateur c'est pas parce qu'il dit
gaffe il dit blender où il dit
point d'exclamation coup brillant etc
qu'on a rien à comprendre c'est pas vrai
l'ordinateur
des fois même d'ailleurs ça doit vous
arriver peut-être de faire un coup
brillant sans faire exprès ou ou de
faire un mauvais coup
par exemple
mais ou alors de faire de faire
un coup à deux points d'interrogation
sans comprendre pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
mal joué et du coup en fait c'est bien
d'essayer de comprendre avec quelqu'un
qui peut vous expliquer quoi donc c'est
l'idée après à bas niveau c'est pas
facile de de déchiffrer vraiment
l'ordinateur donc
tu parles de lecture de d'ordinateur je
pense que c'est à partir de 2200 qu'on
commence à bien lire ordinateur parce
qu'on est on est assez fort pour
comprendre ce qu'il raconte dans la
majorité des cas et lire l'ordinateur
c'est vraiment le travail de
l'entraîneur qui va sélectionner dans
une partie les moments clés que vous
allez pouvoir comprendre pour progresser
et l'ordinateur c'est un formidable
outil pour les entraîneurs que nous
sommes pour préparer l'analyse et
accélérer notre travail en fait
d'analyse et comme ça on sélectionne les
bons moments pour les élèves selon les
niveaux des fois on cache une partie de
la vérité quand le joueur est plutôt
débutant ou amateur premier niveau on va
pas tout dire on va pas être exhaustif
mais on va revenir sur les moments clés
et tactiques et stratégiques mais bien
dit cette lecture d'ordinateur stouf
j'aime bien le terme
donc du coup voilà pour ceux qui
débutent et qui veulent vraiment
analyser les parties ce qui est
important l'analyse des parties c'est
c'est un des points les plus importants
pour progresser aux échecs et ben
l'ordinateur c'est pas forcément votre
meilleur ami voilà donc
qui dit est-ce que l'ordinateur le plus
évolué peut défendre cette partie pas du
tout même si mlbc nous a dit oui bien
sûr non non l'ordinateur le plus évolué
peut rien faire dans cette position
complètement foutue
même contre un pc assez moyen donc non
non là il y a trop d'écart comme on le
disait vraiment tous les signaux sont
ouverts donc l'ancien deep blue là ne
ferait rien
l'ordinateur cesse là qui suit Carlson
ne fait rien non plus
frites 2 contre
le dernier stock fiche ou contre c'est
ce que tu veux bah ça va gagner hein
a priori
[Musique]
l'avantage est tellement énorme que la
partie elle est perdue quoi tout
simplement
les échecs étaient plus romantiques sans
les ordis tu as tout à fait raison
il n'empêche que dans le milieu de jeu
les joueurs ont évolué et sont un peu
plus créatifs quand même
accepte plus facilement de donner du
matériel qu'auparavant bon après ce
courant là existait à partir des années
80-90 même Fisher état l'avait déjà
compris mais il y a maintenant une plus
grande popularité pour ce jeu
calculatoire et et du coup risquer avec
des sacrifices etc un peu plus abstrait
dans les ouvertures oui on ne peut plus
jouer du tout romantique à cause des
ordis d'ailleurs
renverser l'échiquier pourquoi pas pour
Fabiano
si on veut s'en sortir mais ce sera par
la petite porte de toute façon qui va
qui va sortir aujourd'hui Fabiano qui
qui va perdre de manière expéditive
F4 il défend la tour C1 parce que son
cloué et maintenant ça va être fou bouge
voilà direct à tempo le Cavalier Blanc
va bouger on va échanger les tours et on
va ramasser le pion a avec
donc
l'abandon est proche c'est fini est-ce
qu'on fait un petit tour
est-ce que vous voulez finir la partie
avant de changer sachant que là je pense
que dans quelques minutes dans quelques
minutes on va on va on va assister à
l'abandon de Caravana
est-ce que vous voulez finir ou est-ce
qu'on fait un petit tour
il y a un tour pour tag on attend pour
Genève
c'est partager
vous aimez bien ce moment où le joueur
tend la main François qui fait qui fait
une pause avant de de d'essayer de
repasser la barre fatidique de 2000
je dis ça je dis rien
et ben ça y est c'est terminé on a bien
fait d'attendre c'était très rapide
très rapide
un peu vert en partie en 20 coups bon
c'est trop cool mais au bout d'un coup
c'était déjà terminé donc ouais bon
racine qui est bien il est content il se
relance un peu en tournoi avec deux
vecteurs d'affilée et demain il y aura
les blancs donc du coup intéressant
d'ailleurs contre qui jouera demain
Kartel
demain il aura les blancs tu vois il lui
reste blanc ou cache noir par homme
blanc chaud blanc Prague et noir et
regazi donc il a quand même moyen de de
faire peut-être au moins trois victoires
quoi sur la 5 qui reste
qui nous dit pause demain non
oui exactement demain c'est la pause
d'ailleurs merci donc pour la prochaine
partie du coup mais du coup demain c'est
la pause
tu poses pour tout enfin demain c'est la
pause après apprendre encore deux jours
où je serai je serai mardi avec
on est quel jour là excuse-moi on est
dimanche on est dimanche
donc demain c'est lundi demain c'est
demain c'est la pause c'est la pause et
je serai avec avec Fabienne et bizetzki
du coup mardi
et mercredi salut Fatou comment tu vas
mercredi je serai avec un invité
surprise je voulais pas encore dire vous
verrez bien qui c'est je ne vous le dis
pas c'est un invité surprise mercredi et
à partir de jeudi ce sera du coup bon
jeudi ça sera genre de repos et vendredi
c'est Kevin qui me remplacea aux
commentaires en tout cas au
commandement de la technique très bien
je vous le dis soyez indulgent c'est ça
donc Kevin qui va remplacer la technique
et qui aura comme invité du coup
vendredi ben la légende d'un française
Laurent Freyssinet voilà et ensuite
ensuite le samedi et ben
le retour de l'invité qui est aussi une
légende du coup une légende sur twitch
et l'homme était mystère et du coup du
coup dimanche et ben tu seras encore aux
commandes avec du coup Mathieu cornette
exactement voilà il y a aussi une
légende de ma catégorie en France plein
de légendes sur sur ce stream exactement
donc bien sûr on sait pas compter mais
on sait bien sûr que nous sommes aussi
des légendes
[Rires]
alors le nombre d'anecdotes racontées
les rois pour annoncer le résultat à la
machine comme ça on met le roi sur les
cases noires si les Noirs ont gagné sur
les cases blanches
si les Blancs ont gagné en face à face
pour déclencher on va dire le résultat
nul voilà du coup pour savoir qui est
l'invité mystère et ben il faudrait
devenir il faudra venir les gars ce sera
du coup mercredi après-midi pour le
premier épisode parce que du coup le
samedi sera le même invité
donc mercredi en tout cas 14h donc mardi
c'est Libye et mercredi c'est l'invité
mystère
alors du coup
pas loin de Shakira il y en a qui sont
motivé
ça reste un stream et chaque
ah oui ah oui bon après
mais on n'est pas loin nous a dit
robinsided
[Rires]
donc so alors ceux qui a une position
qui est toujours intéressante avec une
pression sur la case blanche la
diagonale mais que s'est-il passé parce
qu'il y avait qu'à une position qui a la
valeur très très avantageuse même si bon
là il est pas mal encore mais on va voir
c'est un petit peu évaporé effectivement
dab 2
donc il y a un pion isolé en E6 mais à
priori Marie s'en fout un peu et si la
case des 5 est bien contrôlée et ben
écoute
il y a eu F3 pour choisir le cavalier
qui pourra venir sûrement c'est 5 à un
jour
dame FC d'un pro je prends F4 qui
contrôle du coup la poussée 5
et du coup bah écoute un petit précis
encore une fois parce que c'est pas
simple de gérer tout ce qui se passe sur
la sur la diagonale blanche
et mais c'est vrai que la position j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu plus
rééquilibré ouais
de
possibilités pour prendre l'avantage en
tout cas petit pressing blanc quand même
mais rien de fait
donc ça c'était pour sodiing est-ce
qu'on continue un petit tour des stades
sauf pour voir un petit peu où ça en est
où là c'est bizarre ça l'attaque des
pions noirs
il faut monter le roi
et là du coup alors on s'est arrêté
pas facile à évaluer G4
c'est 5 donc il y a toujours un pion
plus pour les blancs mais quand même une
belle initiative pour les noirs avec la
paire de foot qui est assez active les
cavaliers qui jouent pas trop
et puis il y a surprise quand même
pour défendre le pion c'est un peu
passifs en prise je peux manger là sur
la prise là je peux manger ça
ou du foulard
s de fou pour compenser le pion de moins
et le pion de moins pour l'instant est
un peu un peu bloqué
j'aimerais bien tenter un fou B5
peut-être à terme pour
sur fulpron C5 peut-être
vous prend puis on prend et tout
redeuil
tu vas essayer des plumes là
en fait je veux bien faire foudre
puis on prend tous deux j'ai carré des
trois tatines extrémistes
et du coup mon cavalier est vraiment
bien tes pions sont c'est chaud
un coup de cavalier modeste en F1
je peux venir là
j'essaie de tenir avec vous voyez c'est
un petit peu un petit peu rude forcément
côté blanc mais si on arrive à tenir bon
on peut contrer un
que j'ai toujours cavalier prend F4 à un
moment peut-être
mais bon
c'est pas sûr ce que je raconte
c'est encore enfin c'est équilibré quoi
vous voyez le type enfin on a comme un
bon exemple de petit film qui pour
arriver sous avec une pression mais moi
j'essaie de défendre voilà je pense que
ça c'est logique qu'on fait
en tout cas pression quand même des
blancs
pardon dans cette position donc mais
après bon
peut-être que gamer peut juste essayer
de liquider un prise prise C4 et se dire
bon ok dans cette dans cette partie
tous les risques s'ils sont danger
je vais vous mettre derrière une caméra
après dans toutes ces belles parties
souvent il a craqué dans ce tournoi donc
on va voir si confirme
on va aller voir les autres
les autres copains
yes donc du coup rapport Prague
du coup il est à jeu le petit H6
a été joué il veut pas jouer des cartes
il veut pas
affaiblir son petit pion on n'avait pas
vu c'est un super coup tu vois enfin il
faut y penser pour moi j'ai joué des
cadres machines allemands et ce qui est
marrant c'est que il a vu cavalier F6 et
en fait
s'il fait tour à chant Kevin et ben il y
a un truc tu sais c'est que la position
c'était la même
super c'est hyper intéressant en fait
voilà là je vais là je vais parler aussi
un peu arbitrage
attention s'il y a gagné
est là on va appeler Gaïa Gaïa au
tableau s'il te plaît
en fait
l'idée c'est qu'en fait regarde bien on
peut imaginer que dans cette position
gardez on a cette position là on est au
14e coup d'accord
moi je fais cavaler j'ai 4
et il joue tout au F1 et là je fais
cavalier F6 si les Blancs jouent tour à
champ
d'accord ça fait deux fois la même
position d'accord si je fais ça qui fait
ça je fais ça et ça fait trois fois la
même position
question pour Kevin est-ce que les noirs
peuvent réclamer la nul
alors ils peuvent réclamer la nuit ils
peuvent réclamer la nul mais ils auront
pas raison ils auront pas raison
pourquoi est-ce que du coup je peux pas
faire nul pas trop voilà une position
c'est incroyable quand même on est on
est dans une position où il y a eu trois
fois la même position quoi
c'est fou quoi exactement mais attention
faut que ça soit trois fois exactement
la même image et le même trait donc ça a
l'air d'être la même image et le même
trait ouais mais même position bah il
faut le même nombre de coupes aussi
possible etc or là par rapport à la
position initiale tu veux nous dire
qu'il y avait un coup supplémentaire
en fait il faut la même possible
position le même trait et aussi les
mêmes possibilités et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que au 14ème coup je vais
revenir
quand on joue qu'à SG4 l'aile blanc ont
le droit de roquet
et du coup bon ils l'ont pas fait
d'accord donc une fois que je fais tout
refait
c'est la même position après qu'elle LG
4 mais une fois qu'on a joué la première
suite et ben ici les blancs peuvent plus
croquer et donc du coup c'est pas la
même position qu'avant on dit que c'est
pas la même position parce qu'il y a une
position où tu peux ok et tu prends la
même image même position on peut plus
roquet du coup c'est pas la même
position voilà c'est bête mais c'est
comme ça et donc du coup ben si on fait
trois fois d'imposition et ben non ça
fait que deux fois parce que la première
elle compte pas voilà donc la règle pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas on a le
droit de réclamer l'annule si la une
troisième fois la même position va
apparaître et là tout vient nous
expliquer un cas particulier
je vais te dire non parce qu'un pion ça
recule pas donc tu aurais du mal de
faire la peine trois fois l'imposition
avec un pion qui avance il peut pas
reculer le pion tu vois donc dans l'idée
j'ai envie de dire oui parce que s'il y
a une possibilité d'avoir un coup
spécial oui mais un pion ne recule pas
donc du coup tu ne pourrais pas avec un
pion tu vois mais
en fait si je joue enfin je vois ce
qu'il veut dire sauf c'est imaginons des
cartes j'ai une première position
ensuite je joue deux coups de cavaliers
et ça serait la même chose que ce qu'on
explique là
ok ok bon dans ce cas là dans ce cas là
c'est moi qui mal compris et donc je
m'en excuse et du coup et ben c'est le
même truc c'est pareil parce que tu as
une position où tu peux faire le
présentation et tu as une position ou tu
ne peux pas la faire donc en fait bah
c'est pas la même position parce que il
y a pas la même possibilité simplement
c'est tout bête mais ça c'est les règles
qu'il faut savoir donc quand vous faites
nul enfin qu'on voit calmer la nuit en
tout cas il faut qu'il ait la même
position soit le même trait par exemple
si c'est au blanc de jouer alors
commence ton genre ça compte plus quoi
ça marche pas c'est pas la même position
parce qu'avant c'était un mois de jouer
etc donc il faut voir les possibilités
le trait et et la position quoi
cette position Yuma elle est enfantin
alors j'ai
bah Hummer regarde j'ai donné un exode
logique à Yuma que tu que tu connais un
Kevin qui est quelque chose qui pour toi
et
assez comment dire
connu quoi je basique que tu connais ça
Kevin n'est-ce pas oui
tu connais c'est pas très compliqué bon
et ben il a décidé je cite il a décidé
que cette position ne pouvait pas
l'atteindre au bout de quatre coups et
voilà il fallait juste voir roi E7 il
faut prendre S7 c'est si c'est fou et
huit faut prendre et reprend à 8 donc du
coup sur ce Yuma
première fois qu'on m'avait donné
j'avais pas trouvé je crois non mais tu
peux ne pas trouver mais bon j'ai décidé
que ça marchait pas
c'était évident bah oui c'est évident
mais faut réfléchir quoi non il y a pas
de JB il y a pas de règle qui indique un
nombre de coups maximum entre les
répétitions si la position n'est pas si
la 3 les trois fois la même position ne
sont pas successives ça marche quand
même on peut donc avoir cette position
en finale aux 60e 80e et 90e qui se
répètent et là tu peux tu peux réclamer
ouais tu peux leur sortir comme des fois
avant de jouer normalement il y a une
procédure pour réclamer la Gaya n'est
pas là donc on va pas la rappeler si
règles mais maintenant quand on écrit
sur une feuille un coup enfin quand on
joue un coup en fait et ben il faut
écrire son coup après avoir joué avant
on pouvait on pouvait si on voulait
noter son coup et après jouer le coup
maintenant ça interdit et maintenant on
joue son coup on appuie sur la pendule
et après on note son coup et du coup
pour la demande de nul pour trois fois
la même position et bien ce qu'il faut
faire c'est que
on va noter notre coup sur la feuille
pour une fois que c'est fait voilà avant
de jouer pendant on ne joue pas on joue
surtout pas donc on va du coup
on va du coup noter le coup sur la
feuille on arrête la pendule et qu'on
appelle l'arbitre et on dit l'arbitre
voilà je vais jouer ça et ça fera une
position donc l'arbitre
alors qu'il est tout jeune et c'est bien
c'est bien de connaître ça l'idiot il
nous l'avait donné direct super parce
que si tu le fais pas c'est tu te
trompes dans la manière l'arbitre peut
te dire que ben non c'est une mauvaise
demande et comme c'est une mauvaise
demande il peut te la refuser et
rajouter du temps adversaire donc en
gros bon voilà mais après des fois il y
a des gens aussi qui font des demandes
aussi pour embêter l'adversaire des fois
ils font un peu du bluff etc on en a vu
donc souvent des petites histoires
autour de cette règle là et c'est vrai
qu'il y en a qui sont verts des fois
parce qu'il ne respecte pas bien la
procédure et l'adversaire souhaite
continuer et peut continuer parce que
quand on répète trois fois la même
position
ça pourrait être logique de la répéter
une quatrième fois mais des fois vous
avez une autre variante potentielle
voyez souvent c'est le joueur le plus
fort qui souhaite continuer et quitte à
être un petit peu moins bien une
position un peu près égale juste parce
qu'il y a une sorte d'effet
psychologique de l'adversaire qui s'est
vu refuser sa procédure de nulle parce
qu'il a mal faite et souvent les plus
forts et c'est après de battre à la
régulière mais les joueurs adverses et
ça fait souvent des histoires je viens
de voir que guéri et Kemer avait fait
nul
ah oui des prank propose de
elle a eu peur
[Musique]
donc pour l'instant
non on a faux là
c'est pas mal
pour l'instant on a zéro sur deux au
niveau des pronoms on était d'accord
c'est déjà bien souffle on a pas 0 sur 2
on a 1 sur 3 quand même sur 3 oui c'est
vrai il y a eu la nul
1 sur 3
et 5 a été joué du coup on en parlait
tout à l'heure
du coup quand on a 5 minutes chaos alors
déjà il y a beaucoup enfin maintenant
les cadences lentes avec 5 enfin les
cadences clanks en ko ça existe plus
enfin ou très très peu donc du coup ça
arrivera pas
et puis il y a aussi les directs qui ont
changé c'est que l'arbitre en fait a le
droit de
a le droit à l'arbitre de de donner la
nul si il voit lui-même 5 fois la même
position déjà donc
après bon
tout ce qui a envie c'est rapide cette
règle là elle est pas trop applicable
parce que
je peux pas prouver moi je peux me dire
trois fois l'imposition j'appelle
l'Arabie
ben non ben comment je trouve en fait tu
vois donc ça après dans les parties
retransmises comme je peux aller du
monde etc on peut le prouver je pense
parce que c'est la partie qui sont
retransmis sur Internet son suivi par le
tournoi etc on a déjà été mais si on
joue sur un échiquier en carton
et qu'en fait
il est pas retransmis et ben il y a pas
moyen de prouver qu'on a fait trois fois
d'imposition donc du coup bah ça
s'applique pas trop après même
maintenant les cadences même en rapides
les cadences chaos on voit quasi plus
donc toute façon il y a le temps enfin
si la position est nulle de toute façon
souvent elle est nulle quoi
alors à chaque fois je te regarde
dans mon coin ouais
on m'avait dit qu'il fallait que je
supprime les données de stockage en truc
comme ça et je l'ai fait et puis après
ça continuait à m'arriver le problème
mais du coup après avoir
enfin le lendemain en fait bah ça
marchait mieux parce que du coup j'avais
redémarrer l'ordi entre temps enfin
voilà et Tonton hâte de voulait savoir
comment
comment réussissait enfin comment on
faisait pour proposer nul c'est
effectivement
en fin de tour de jeu c'est c'est juste
dans la proposition doit intervenir dans
le prolongement du fait que tu joues ton
cou c'est à dire que tu joues ton cou tu
appuies sur la pendule et là tu proposes
nul c'est normalement comme ça que ça
doit se faire
et ensuite il y a ça et ben c'est une
volonté les échelles électroniques
pourraient détecter trois fois la même
position à terme il y a pas cette
fonctionnalité mais c'est au joueur de
demander parce que tous les échiquiers
ne sont pas électroniques et c'est une
procédure à appliquer voilà donc c'est
un petit peu différent
voilà il y a eu il y a une gaffe là de
vente forest avec cavalue 2
et après ta F7 regarde
pourquoi c'est une gaffe ça
on va trouver
cavalier 2
[Musique]
ça choque pas les cavalise marche un
petit peu de jus un petit peu dessus et
ce qu'on pouvait travailler autour du
pion C4 sans doute que oui
est-ce que c'était C5
j'ai pensé à c'est simple pour ouvrir la
colonne mais je bouge mon cavale quelque
part
suite pour travailler le pion C4 ça m'a
l'air un peu étonnant si c'est ça qu'il
a été raté
parce que ça a pas l'air très simple à 4
c'est sympa autrement
beaucoup de coup autre
[Musique]
de fois 4 je sais pas si je le jouais
directement vous avez froid c'était
mieux parce que là j'ai cavaler des
cartes qui a l'air sympa j'ai des cases
je crois qu'il paraît plus tard
très intéressant
ça a l'air d'être ça grosso modo
tu auras du mal à avoir accès ton
cavalier ici
[Musique]
de tous les côtés
ok du coup dans mes fesses raté
et du coup
P5 C5
cavaler c'est dans les livres hein kssi
ce qu'on voit de manière thématique pour
les cases des 1 pour les cases B5 et la
vente de regarder
[Musique]
un pion fin de Forest pour en fait si
vous voulez une fois qu'on récupère le
pion et ben avoir un cavalier sûrement
en B5 qui va attaquer le pion à 7 et qui
en plus bloque la tour ici en C6 donc ce
cavalet il est quand même assez fort
quoi s'il ne fait rien on a dit on se
fait enfoncé à terme avec G5 g4.5 G5 G4
et on se prendrait la grosse attaque
donc faut entreprendre quelque chose au
centre c'est ce que fait parfaitement
van forest avec ce kssis
donc c'est intéressant
en tout cas c'est une partie un nom dans
les parieurs sur la victoire devant
Forrest moi sur la victoire de iriasi
pour l'instant tout est possible encore
intéressant prendre google j'ai parlé
sur Google
on va voir un peu ce qui se passe il y a
toujours son petit pion isolé
on s'est arrêté ou on s'est arrêté il y
a
un moment
on sait pas si qui avait la carte
cavalier 5 il est venu en A4 et voyez il
a pas mangé depuis on mangeait le pion
de tout à l'heure on en a parlé ça a
gagné un pion mais bon ça offre quand
même contre la paire de fou et toujours
un petit peu mieux clairement mais
il y avait des idées
donc là il y a eu cavalier c'est 5
attaque le pion B7 prise 5
il défend encore une fois chaque échange
favorise les
pardon les blancs ils travaillent donc
du coup cavalier 3 faut prendre
c'est un petit peu
bizarre effectivement un aveu
d'impuissance mais il y a cavalier F4
qui est arrivé peut-être souffre en plus
du reste mais cavaliers F4 a l'air très
pénible et si je joue je sens quand même
on voit bien que c'est clairement que la
position ne va pas du tout
c'est
ultra ultra chiant et du coup on
changeait 5 il se dit bah écoute
donc il y a plus de cavaliers
B4 à 6 à 4 donc il veut jouer à il veut
jouer des 5 chasser le cavalier mettre
le cavalier ici et continuer la tête
quoi donc
là il joue à 5 qui est intéressant qui
veut continuer à prendre des cartes ou
B7 sur blanc pour travailler
donc là quand même
belle position de travail de cocache là
je suis pas du tout malheureux d'avoir
voté pour lui
et je pense qu'il va faire le taf
de gagner ce qui fera bien mes affaires
je te rappelle qu'on a que deux trucs
qui sont
[Musique]
différents
pour l'instant au niveau du jeu des
pronos
si on jouait contre la banque on serait
perdant oui on serait bien perdant
en tout cas après signe gros pressing de
goûtech donc on va aller peut-être voir
rapport Prague
alors rapport Prague
tout à l'heure du coup donc il y avait
eu du coup Tour Eiffel il est revenu
dame c'est de Fougères
et donc là les blancs peuvent ok quand
même de ce côté là c'était pas dit à
moins que tu veuilles faire une autre
règle
x 5 il y a eu qui avaler prend un S4 et
pour les Noirs parce que évidemment
s'ils prennent l'option H5 c'est de
grosses possibilités dans les rock
opposés sur le moyen terme donc les rock
opposés ici sont très favorables au
blanc il y a une meilleure densité de
pièces
pour D1 pourquoi pas ça doit permettre
E5 sur des 5
pas de réaction et maintenant on va se
diriger tranquillement vers les lois
voilà et vous voyez que les perspectives
blanches sont vraiment meilleures côté
droit on a énormément de jeux sur foo
prend f3g prend un F3 et on ouvre deux
colonnes sur le roi avec des yeux tours
pardon et sur un coup comme dame.fr
il y aurait des des motifs très
intéressants pour aller pour aller mater
le roi noir des dames franchise
parce que il y aurait
beaucoup trop de jeux
sur
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien jouer pour G4 G5 donc
peut-être que sur fougy j'aurais tout H3
pour doubler pour G4
donc le roi qui enseigne ici pourra
toujours alors se faire attaquer un
faire un peu attention mais c'est que
pour l'instant bah c'est plutôt le roi
de Prague qui qui va souffrir
il a joué
trois qui peut aussi arriver vous voyez
qu'il y a un petit vis-à-vis ici que le
Fuge 6 pourrait rentrer aussi être sous
pression dans plein de position
on va essayer d'améliorer les pièces
on avait aussi peut-être des cavaliers
H4
et le pion F2 n'était pas vraiment en
l'air
avantage 3 je pense que c'est vraiment
une belle idée
j'aime bien ton coup j'ai 6 du coup
est-ce que peut-être que je peux garder
mon fond en G4 mais bon cavalier H2 mais
une idée de cavalier de Fougères ça peut
être aussi
se fout quoi qui peut être redoutable
et
mais bon j'ai un problème quand même sur
mon roi quoi tout le monde veut prendre
les blancs ici ça sent on est mieux dans
la roc opposés donc ça donne envie
pour l'instant Richard rapporte fait une
très très jolie partie d'ailleurs Prague
aussi c'est une partie intéressante les
joueurs sont juste un peu lents 22 coups
il leur reste 11 et 17 minutes
un peu d'abus à ce niveau là alors
je comprends
une pièce et ça paraît très inspiré
parce que le genou noir allait le roi va
mettre trop de temps à se mettre en
place donc maintenant c'est le combat
qui commence au centre et à l'aile dame
on a beau avoir sacré une pièce
il est blanc gagne B6 sans donner trop
de matériel on gagnera la partie puisque
nos deux pions vont se mettre en marche
on a cavalier A4 cavaliers
je sais pas comment il faut le prendre
mais ça a l'air très dangereux
alors comment il est arrivé là juste
parce qu'on s'est arrêté à B5 c'est 5
avalé C6 il y a je tourne D7 de contrôle
et il a vachement d'initiative sur le
pion V6 et pendant que les pièces noires
et Ben sont ici à plus faire grand-chose
et bien c'est l'option c'est le premier
c'est ce qui risque de tomber en tout
cas créatif encore une fois c'est
souvent le Forest belle partie entre les
deux joueurs et moi ce que j'aime
vraiment beaucoup avec ces joueurs qui
jouent le bien tout le temps et et peu
importe le tournoi tout ça ils vont ils
arrivent toujours à se motiver
pour essayer de gagner quoi c'est
vraiment super mentalité
souffre parce que effectivement vente
Forest a fait l'une de ses pires parties
peut-être depuis longtemps
parce que hier il s'est fait rouler
dessus par Prague et le lendemain il est
là il tient le stand il est parti pour
faire une partie
vraiment complexe et on y va on essaie
de gagner comme tu le dis bah c'est tout
à son honneur et c'est comme ça qui qui
va qui va continuer sa progression
évidemment en tout cas dans le concept
est bon il va falloir prendre C4 sans
doute un moment pour pour essayer de
trouver du contre jeu avec des noirs
parce que sinon le Cavalier Blanc va
venir en dessin et on va s'installer
vraiment
avec les blancs dans une position très
favorable même si au niveau de matériel
on a investi en réalité on a investi un
pion puisqu'on a donné une pièce contre
deux pions on a en plus quand même
beaucoup de jeux je pense qu'il faut
essayer de prendre en C4 mais c'est
vraiment complexe en position
cyber compliqué et en plus ryazi qui qui
est ultra matérialiste on l'a vu hier il
est très matérialiste et puis en plus il
a il adore tout ce qui est tactique tout
ça donc c'est compliqué
qui a pris en F3 apparemment on nous dit
Zara merci à toi de suivre la partie il
a pris F3 et du coup
les Indiens sous nous disait qu'il Regis
et était matérialiste c'est dans cette
position sous je vais jouer le tour EG1
enfin dans la position de la regarder
juste après juste j'avais une question
sur ton but tu joues comment
je voudrais bien cavalier dessin
il y a Cavalia
je me dis bon peut-être que je peux
manger là
de verrouiller la peau
et je peux manger et je prends du pion e
ok
il y a toujours les problèmes là mais là
j'ai la pièce de plus encore qui m'a pas
encore montre d'options parce que dessin
et dessin qui est assis sont très fort
quand même et j'ai des motifs comme tu
les énonçais sauf de un moment faire
[ __ ] français sans un coup tout
reprend B6 comme tu l'as dit j'ai encore
mes motifs avec le fou braquer tu as pu
t'en fout de casse blanche mon four F1
pourra sortir en Détroit moment
intéressant quand même je préfère les
blancs ici à titre perso
débile alors attends il n'a pas du tout
ça très intéressant je l'avais pas vu
dans l'idée
ou l'autre d'ailleurs mais je t'enlève
tes pompons majeur quoi
avec une tour de plus l'avantage c'est
qu'on peut rendre du matériel et l'idée
moi ce que je voulais c'était essayer de
d'avoir une position du type bah ok je
bouge mon cavalier pour défendre tout et
je recule mon fou et puis bah je
poussais tous mes pions vous voyez la
paire de fou et les pions qui avancent
ça a l'air il y a une cavalière qui est
possible ça a l'air ultra dur et
d'ailleurs cette pensée à la partie de
vente forest contre
maxoo un parrain qu'on a vu il y a
quelques rondes maintenant
mais un thème contre comme tout le monde
contre romain Edouard en 2004 première
table de l'accession il m'a sacrifié sa
dame pour avoir les petits pions b&A qui
avancent comme ça sur la sixième c'était
magnifique bon sur le moment je trouvais
pas ça magnifique et évidemment parce
que j'étais
en perdition totale et mais c'est
magnifique ce genre de sacrifice comme
tout le monde là pour avoir les pions
qui avance la mets les blanches mais on
peut le faire de manière un petit peu
plus économique là dans cette partie en
tout cas très très jolie sacrifice de
grande forêt ce qui est en pratique
risque de prendre l'ascendant
falloir que cargazer trouve
les cours
si vous le regardez il est tout le temps
en train de regarder le public et
regarde les gens et il est calcule là
vous pensez qu'il regarde ce qui passe à
côté et en fait il calcule et personne
ne lui fait signe vous inquiétez pas il
n'y a pas besoin de ça mais très souvent
my calcul en fait enlevant la tête quoi
il avait il a les yeux un peu au ciel et
calcule un peu comme dans la série un
équipe on le voyait comme ça ah oui
série le jeu de la dame ouais c'est vrai
ça lui va bien
c'est un peu caricaturé mais c'est
certains joueurs c'est un grand joueur
qui arrive tout le monde pourrait le
faire mais eux ils le font tout le temps
parce que ils sont très à l'aise à
l'aveugle tout simplement
OK et du coup est-ce qu'on irait
rapidement retourner voir la position de
Prague pour voir qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu
parce que j'ai l'impression que Richard
apporte vous pouvez peut-être avoir une
attaque gagnante souffre
alors du coup oui donc il a il a mangé
F3 il a pas eu peur et là on pouvait
imaginer un tour EG1 avec une
tu reprends le 7 reprend le 7 damage si
c'est chèque et dame là donc surtout
rejoins
pardon excuse-moi tout rogéen d'un F2 et
surtout j'essaie de roi F8 j'ai oublié
tout à l'heure ça peut faire mal en fait
ce qui peut avoir raté
[Musique]
du coup
je peux pas du tout
faire ça
fait très peur est-ce que ce serait
qu'il y a toujours ton G7 en plus ah non
non roi et flic peut-être
parce que
il y a ça du coup
ça a été joué dans la partie en fait
directement par un tour 2
là on arrive à vous expliquer à
vulgariser un peu le truc en bougeant
les pièces
là
donc il a vu que sur Tours j'ai un
c'était roi F8 qui l'embêtait donc il
veut garder il veut garder cette menace
là tours géant parce que maintenant sur
wi-fuite on aurait tout reprend G7 parce
que notre tour n'est plus en l'air en H1
donc il défend la tour-acha et le pion
F2 avec ce coup là c'est c'est juste du
beau jeu parce que c'est une sorte de
temporisation sauf alors que on dit
toujours qui normalement faut aller
c'est la course à l'attaque les rock
opposés et là un petit coup de frein et
dit je vais je vais t'attraper plus tard
franchement là c'est du très très haut
niveau ce que l'on voit là j'adore
il y avait quoi sur tout reprend un fils
[Musique]
c'est intéressant pour un 6
malheureusement tu ne sais rien
réellement donc peut-être faut prendre
F2
ce que je prends un schiste si vous
voulez faire dam prend un je pense et là
je devais mettre
embêter en tout cas ah peut-être c'est
pas sûr
tu peux aussi
bien sûr
[Musique]
on peut déjà bouffer même sans bouffer
je voulais faire faux F2 direction
donc d'entourage 2 c'est un coup
brillantissime
je pense que Richard apporte avec ce
courageux va peut-être prendre une
option sur la position souffre je trouve
très dur de trouver un coup pour les
noirs
je n'y arrive plus est-ce que tu as une
idée sauf toi de ton côté moi je vois la
jauge qui monte pour les blancs quand
même mais je me dis que s'il y a rien de
concret les Noirs vont finir par être
par être mieux et je ne vois pas du tout
ce qu'on pourrait faire on va descendre
qui pourrait être un coup
dans le chat et merci pour les petits
mots
et pour l'instant c'est d'où ça t'auras
qui mène le tournoi
l'évêque
du coup on a une partie brillante de
deux Magnus qui revient à là il vient de
gagner il vient de prendre deux sur deux
lui qui était en difficulté dans le
tournoi il est complètement revenu
alors et du coup tu as trouvé quelque
chose là parce que t'embêter moi je
galère bah non je trouve pas
les fesses
[Musique]
donc
c'est pas mal à tout moment je pourrais
jouer décapant plus
G7 et là peut-être le coup de dame F6
des 5 je voulais jouer tout reprend G7
surtout fais ce que je peux maintenant
non je pensais faire je pensais avoir
attends j'ai d'autres je vais peut-être
un coup que je viens de trouver un peu
au pif je pense avoir trouvé le coup au
pif
heureusement que tu me l'as dit parce
que je me serais fait pigeonner
c'est pas si bête
mais
4 et je te dis qu'en fait
c'est la deuxième fois qui aura un coup
pour contrôler c'est beau ton H4 c'est à
la fois encore esthétique
donc du coup c'est pas encore
signification
qui revient du coup cinquième mais c'est
pas vrai encore
parce que on a pas mal de joueurs qui
ont encore 7 points vous voyez encore
Prague qui a 7 points
du tableau quand même Prague s'il est en
difficulté il reste là et Magnus il
revient très très bien il est qu'à un
demi point du podium maintenant
au Paris d'hier c'est un super bête
parce que c'est le pari que tu m'aimes
c'est le pari en mieux que tu m'avais
proposé la veille dans l'autre sens
parce que pour l'instant
je te maltrait pas au niveau des subs
bon c'est pas fini après il reste qui
d'ailleurs
c'est pas mal de jeunes en plus ouais
encore et parrain merguez rapport fin de
Forest et Google sont encore en train de
jouer leur partie donc
gagner en plus on a enterré un peu vite
souvent les commentaires vous savez dans
les médias ça va assez vite dès que
Carlsen perd deux parties c'est la
grosse enflammade
et du coup je pense que ça le pique un
petit peu au vif en tant compétiteur et
il doit avoir très très envie de de
revenir
en étant passé par
par le fond
de la cave parce que quand il avait pris
ses deux bulles c'est pas facile de s'y
remettre
une petite nulle avec vent de Forest et
l'abîme rapporte avec les Blancs et
surtout Fabiano aujourd'hui qui l'a bien
aimé quand même il a cette petite
réussite voilà
faut pas enterrer
très clairement
oui oui
mais hier il a fait une très très jolie
partie en fait ça fait deux parties où
il fait pas de fautes quand même
et la partie de vente forest était là
aussi très bonne donc si il est de
retour à
son meilleur niveau
en ayant essuyé
un moment difficile alors on a soading
qui vont faire nul est-ce que tu veux
qu'on aille les voir rapidement pourquoi
pas je viens de voir juste le petit coup
de fou D1 de de
Richard Harper donc on n'avait pas du
tout parlé sauf
et c'est
c'est pas facile à anticiper
et vous les jouets pour F4 d'accord et
la position est très agréable à jouer
bah bien sûr on tourne tout d'un F4
allez on va aller vers un petit bug
comme d'hab ouais ça je peux rien y
faire et on passe du coup à la partie de
sodiing où là je pense qu'ils vont
serrer la main
d'ici quelques minutes comme je sais que
vous aimez bien les joueurs qui serrent
la main
et ben je vous ai mis la caméra
alors du coup voilà envoyer des pions
qui vont avancer ça à faire ça ça ça ça
prend celui de propose nulles
je pense
ça joue encore et voilà vous voyez ça
fait nul
[Musique]
ok donc ça on avait encore une fois
raison
dans nos
films
c'est ça on avait encore raison à 50 %.
on est à 50 % en fait il reste les
matchs des matchs en des si en tout cas
il y a des rapports qu'on avait des nuls
même si bon on va voir un peu ce qui se
passe dans la partie
il parle quelle langue il parle anglais
maltraitait par âme et on peut dire que
j'ai l'avantage sur vente forest qui
faisait du mal à irgaliser mais c'était
quand même plus indécis c'est plus
compliqué alors que ça a l'air quand
même d'être un
[Musique]
bon [ __ ] avantage sans risque surtout
comme tu le dis stuff même si il a un
peu mal au temps quand même un petit pas
attention on a vu dans son Zina contre
erwana hier ça s'est mal passé ah oui
surtout que c'est un petit peu avancé
qui il aurait fait une peut-être une
bêtise sauf puisque je vois qu'il y a de
la couleur là sur les coups
on va voir on va aller voir comment ça
avancer ah il a réussi par un à pousser
son pion
on avait dit alors il s'est trompé
quelque part Google parce que
normalement le pion on avait dit que
quand il y a un pion isolé il faut le
bloquer se développer bloquer pressé
depuis tout à l'heure il était bloqué et
assurément il ne risque pas de bouger à
un moment et là il a laissé filer
et en plus il est en or donc c'est pas
le bon moment pour que l'option
s'envole et il y a une très très belle
il avait prévu qui a validé B2 pour
gagner le pion en fait c'est 5 avec
menace de fourchette souffle
et ben je t'annonce que il ne gagnera
plus je pense Google
ça fait hyper mal il a oublié en fait
qui est des 5 vous voyez avec le
vis-à-vis tourner un Dame des 6 et ça
menace cavaler ces trois
alors bon il y a peut-être non il y a
peut-être dame B4 parce que fonctionne
dans le 6 et après
il peut jouer pour gagner
c'était pour essayer d'éteindre la
position mais dame aussi je préfère
toujours cette menace de cavalier C3
hyper embêtant
[Musique]
ici
situation c'est le meilleur moment quand
tu fais un tournoi et que ça se passe
pas bien et que même quand tu es bien et
ben tu tu fais un peu des erreurs de
calcul comme ça c'est un oubliant tu
vois et du coin là et en plus on menace
l'option H3 donc ça peut à tout moment
sauter le pion H3 alors prise D4 hyper
chaud parce que maintenant
il y a cavalier ces trois qui est laissé
et compte peut-être sur une fourchette
avec des 5 ça va être très très tendu un
KFC 3D 5 il y aurait peut-être dame F5
il va falloir tout regarder ça va être
un autre de très haut niveau et c'est
compliqué de jouer ces positions là
quand tu as deux minutes ça me fait
il avait une position tellement
tranquille
qu'il doit vraiment vraiment regretter
qui vient de se passer
attention c'est tendu peut être dame F5
ici sauf très intéressant avec la
cinquième rangée
contrôler
qui est prendre un petit préfère ça
c'est
peut-être encore ok pour les blancs
donc c'est bon ça
et Carlson
noir contre karwana qui a fait une toute
petite partie c'est la partie une
mauvaise partie
on a l'impression que Google est en
train de craquer et en plus il a plus de
temps est-ce qu'il va voir les
ressources mentales
pour
pour tenir je sais pas ce qu'il voulait
dire avec ce il a vu forcément qui a
laissé trois donc qu'est-ce qu'il a
annoncé stouf qu'il avait prévu je sais
pas dame B6 pour attaquer la tour C7
mais bon il y aura beaucoup de choses en
l'air
il y a plein de mêmes
tout en l'air tout en l'air avec une 45
à la pendule donc vous voyez
à l'écran et il vient de regarder sa
feuille de natation il sait qu'il est
encore neuf coup avec une minute à jouer
dans une position archi tendue qu'il a
laissé complètement échapper
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
il est bien apparemment et oui
là ça s'est retourné
et ventes forest c'est ultra chaud
je sais pas comment il a fait pour
[Musique]
la séquence qu'il y a eu on était à
Tours B6 c'est ça sauf tout à l'heure
il vient de jouer avec son 40e il y a
une très belle séquence j'ai
l'impression ça c'est avec voilà on
était là pardon C4 d'accord c'était
normal on prend il faut prendre tout
reprendre ici
waouh
[Musique]
est tellement active tellement agréable
à l'oeil tous nos pièces sont bien
placées a décidé de faire confiance
avant de Forest et de jouer cavalier
prend E5 et la position c'est pas encore
fini
pour des sites très belle partie en tout
cas qui tient toutes ses promesses on
voit le roi noir qui est en danger c'est
ultra bordélique et ça y est ils ont
passé le 40e avec ce tour 8 et la partie
là j'ai peut-être quand même dame F4
parce que j'ai le droit de faire ça
je vais gagner quoi
que tu perds tes pions
c'est durer cette position
un homme c'est dur pour les deux
trois
cavalier prend F3 vous voyez toutes les
histoires est-ce que je fais dame 4
d'abord sauf pour pour surfousser 5
avoir un coup mais c'est pas sûr parce
que après roi H8 ben si je fais pousser
ça il y a toujours qu'à aider trois il y
a des découvertes de partout
c'est un faux amis sans doute peut-être
qu'il faut jouer simple
on prend qui là faut pas que là
est-ce que je peux pas jouer allez
cavaliers 4 avec l'idée
trois tours des trois mais j'ai mon pion
B5 en l'air encore donc j'ai pas envie
en pratique je pense que je prenais
plutôt les noirs
à jouer le 4 au pire peut-être hein
en plus en fait j'ai pensé qu'ici il
faut jouer Dame des deux
je viens de trouver dans des deux coups
très simple
je pensais que c'était ça coup un peu
silencieux
ça semblait tout tenir et conserver un
peu les motifs puisque j'ai mon fou
c'est 5 à jouer et j'ai pas envie de
laisser ma madame
autant dire que j'ai pas prévu de jouer
dame G1
c'est le coup
vicieux
la marque des échiquiers à ma
connaissance c'est toujours déjà
ouais pour moi c'est le style Stanton
mais
faudrait mettre la grosse cam mais je
pense que sur le côté de l'échiquier
c'est indiqué s'ils ont bien fait les
choses au niveau du marketing des
échiquiers ça doit être ça doit être
indiqué
entre les deux feuilles de notation je
sais pas si toi tu vois souffle non je
crois que je crois que c'est écrit
tu vois
des marketing des échiquiers peuvent
encore bosser
les chaude cette position voilà ils ont
passé les années stouf donc on peut
peut-être aller sur un autre échiquier
si ça dérange pas juste pour voir si il
y a des gaps
dans le roi qui est parti en D7 ils sont
30e coup avec 3 minutes entre 5 et le
bocage il est au 36e avec une minute il
s'est passé plein plein de choses
qu'est-ce qu'on regarde
on se met la caméra de 1
[ __ ] je vais faire je vais te faire la
vue là tu es un gars je vais vous
régaler
je vais vous régaler
ça va être je vais vous régaler
sauf que j'ai pas trop de miracles
techniques hein sinon après c'est bien
que je suis complètement dépassé ouais
mais je vais vous mettre une petite une
petite vue là vous inquiétez pas c'est
normal qu'on voit pas encore donc la
partie c'était quoi l'autre c'était un
rapport Prague
rapport Prague rapport Prague et d'un
autre côté goût cache max zoodlu voilà
je vous ai mis les deux
pour le diagnost et puis après on
reprendra les villes normal
pas mal beau boulot
et du coup
parrain il a le Time de jouer
ça a été hyper chaud
était à deux doigts de perdre ensemble
t-il
gokash mais il a trouvé tous les coups
visiblement
et je vide par arme pour mettre la
pression
donc on va avoir tourgé un et ce qu'on
aura cavalier prend à 5 non à cause de
dama 8 gagne le cavalier
donc j'amènerai bien mon mon cavalier à
l'abordage tout et sur kd4
jouer par param en plus ce que je vais
jouer au roi H1
il reste de quoi à jouer avec une minute
indique
égal
mais il y a des nazes de cavaliers de
cavalier F3
est-ce que je joue oui si je dois
maintenant c'est cavalier E2 si je fais
d'habitude
peut-être qu'il y aura
des idées de
d'échecs avec des chèques perpétuels
avec les blancs mais sur dame B8 pour
l'instant je peux encore aller en
Hachette
pour éviter les échecs comment je tiens
ma position avec les Blancs parce que je
suis sous pression souffle
peut-être et chaque roi là
peut-être maintenant roi H1
et oui peut-être que c'est ça mais
qu'est-ce que c'est dur à jouer
de toute façon à un moment
maintenant c'est la partie jouer il est
à 0 H13
en tout cas c'est impressionnant à côté
on voit Google on voit pas très très
bien enfin Prague la partie
[Musique]
alors est-ce que j'ai le droit de jouer
un coup de contrôle comme
comme dame G3
faut pas oublier qu'il y a le petit pion
en A5 à 6 à 7 à 8
réussite maximum pour pour goûter
cavalier F5 très intéressant tout un
menace au moins perpète ça va avec la
vallée G3 cavaliers F1 quelque chose
comme ça
mais est-ce que est-ce que tu vois une
menace
plus forte que cavalier 3 cavaliers
est-ce que
pourquoi pas du coup et là
j'ai gagné un temps avec le noir
donc si je fais roi chaque peut-être ici
[Musique]
mon piège
en tout cas c'est beaucoup pour Google
est-ce qu'on peut jouer G4
attention faut faire gaffe pour les deux
joueurs mais en tout cas là vous cache
il s'en sort super bien
sur dame B8 3G7 il a laissé les chèques
là
donc ton idée de
et peut-être faire maintenant qui avait
3 et faire rouage de du coup parce que
il y a plus il y a plus échec découverte
parce que le droit
et là pour le coup c'est très très chaud
alors en grande difficulté
comme ça au moins vous voyez un petit
peu
[Musique]
un petit peu
la gestuelle des joueurs un peu leur
attitude et tout
il reste pas beaucoup de temps pour les
9 derniers coups d'autresignotent grosse
pression
avec un E6 potentiel qui pour arriver
pour essayer de tout ouvrir mais je
ferai roisser 7 sans doute souffle
donc il doit se demander Richard comment
avancer réellement dans cette position
j'ai aussi j'ai un si j'ai fou B3 j'ai
froid 5
j'aime bien
faut quand même
une belle pression ça fait malin il
s'est passé quoi juste rapidement
[Musique]
ce qui fait Richard rapport dans cette
partie qui joue à un niveau exceptionnel
très très gros sens de l'initiative
comme tu disais
X5
colossal à l'option aussi ce qui
voilà une des suites mais il y en a
plusieurs un peu de ce style là en fait
Richard apporte il a plusieurs bons
coups ici stuff il est en train de voir
comment il doit jouer alors il y a eu
des coups jouets je crois qu'il a bien
fait aussi c'est fou à 5 d'ailleurs il a
choisi la même variante c'est ça sauf
il a formé Prague mais il a pas formé
Google
comme de ça mais c'est pas
c'est pas la même école je crois il en
est en train de
stage aussi avec ramènes tout ça parce
qu'ils se connaissent tous très bien etc
très beau vivier mais c'est pas
c'est enfin deux ce que je sais
c'est pas ces paramètres l'entraîneur
pratique
ans 2480
il faisait le stage à l'aveugle
[Rires]
je sais plus quel âge je me trompe
peut-être
mais très impressionnant
c'est vrai il y avait les études études
très compliquées et vous êtes tout à
l'aveugle quoi
tout simplement
je crois qu'on perd en ligne après tu
reprends F7 tours F7 et suivi de pions
comme ça
il y a peut-être tourner
F7 non j'y crois pas c'est
il y a eu ta ligne voilà
fuite maintenant solidaire avec l'idée
de tout reprendre
enfin c'est pas c'est une demi-idée
et je peux quand même faire tout revu
ton fou est trop mal placé donc ça doit
être dur quand même de faire tout
reprendre
voilà la pression est immense tour
Eiffel jouer
et maintenant est-ce qu'on peut faire
encore mieux que tout re 8 dans cette
position c'est la question
F7 faut prendre donc là on peut on peut
sacrifier la qualité et se dire que
peut-être qu'on peut essayer de jouer ça
quoi
qui est pas l'air terrible
c'est dur mais
je pense que tu as bougé mon roi
je l'avais pas vu mais alors lui il
s'est il mange tous les jours
[Rires]
ça pourrait être une suite comme ça là
en tout cas on voit la grande difficulté
de jouer cette position
encore plus fort
s en plus
et à tout moment je peux jouer même dame
8 qui doit pas être si bête en plus
[Musique]
moi tu me connais
de contrôle
tu sais ce que j'attends tu sais ce que
j'attends
ma tour défends tout et je vais finir le
taf tranquillement alors il y a eu il y
a eu le tour prend il faut prendre un
prank il va y avoir 7 et on va aller
grignoter des pions ça c'est une partie
qui doit être perdu ah oui oui oui
très très content là hier m'a venues
c'est quelque chose que font beaucoup de
gens d'échec
toucher les pièces moi j'ai souvent
tu vois quand je suis pas un problème là
dans l'ordinateur j'ai souvent un truc
dans les mains genre j'ai toujours un
stylo ou j'aime bien avoir un truc dans
les mains tu sais quand je trouve
tripote je suis un tripoter
[Rires]
les airpods j'avais hier là j'ai là
j'avais un stylo dans la main j'ai
toujours un petit truc dans la main et
c'est souvent un pion
et
donc on attend la fin du zinote et après
on pourra retourner voir
Google et Max audlo et aussi et vent
forest ça promet peut-être d'être la
dernière partie hyper chaude je crois
salut à toi je propose nul j'ai pas eu
je t'ai pas vu arriver et
alors hier on a vu quelqu'un qui te
ressemblait beaucoup sur le chat j'aime
pas perdre et j'aime pas perdre et il
était vert comme toi vers
et donc j'aime pas perdre avec je
propose nul c'était un petit peu
malheureusement on n'a pas eu les
j'aurais bien aimé avoir un petit un
petit débat entre vous bah je sais que
c'était pas toi mais du coup
il y aurait pas eu des bas il y aurait
eu entente il y aura eu entendre
[Rires]
oui donc finalement c'était bien Dame
des deux le bon coup à jouer dans cette
position
[Musique]
a fait le choix de la finale il va
bouffer les deux pions
ça a l'air du coup
du coup non ça ça va être très dur ça va
être très dur parce que
[Musique]
le fou il sort pas ou rabbay 8 mais du
coup le roi est inactif et puis du coup
on va manger des pions donc c'est on va
peut-être commencer par le pion F ouais
on peut prendre les deux
a priori ça ça va gagner techniquement
assez facilement normalement
il faut se remettre toujours pareil donc
quand ça gagne elle est belle sa partie
je sais pas combien il a de jusqu'à
présent de précision
je peux regarder j'ai trouvé très
agréable à regarder
en freestyle parce que la partie a eu
grand rock il y a eug4 ou bien enfin tu
sais c'est bon tu vois que c'était pas
forcément contrôlé mais en fait 96 quand
même c'est c'est monstrueux quoi
et ce qui est ouf j'aime pas gagner
aimerait rejoindre le groupe pas mal
j'ai pas gagné
ça doit exister en plus mais
[Musique]
[Rires]
non il sera il sera créé dans la foulée
en tout cas la dure donc 96 de pression
nous disent tout dans cette partie olé
olé
et Prague n'a pas démérité avec un 92
quasiment
il avait les blancs il a rien obtenu il
a trouvé une idée intéressante à une
belle idée mais il a fait une petite
erreur
d'inversion de coupe à un moment clé de
la partie il aurait pu mettre un peu la
pression mais
il a joué un peu vite à ce moment-là et
du coup il s'est fait complètement
neutraliser
le G4 c'est tout à l'heure OK
il se lever
[Rires]
une bonne manière de s'envoyer en l'air
c'est pas une erreur
vous savez qu'il y a un rajout de temps
en 40e
après la 38 on a la pendule à côté
peut-être qu'elle est partie voir un
bouquet
[Musique]
du coup H4
du coup peu importe
ça ça
j'ai vu tout à l'heure jusqu'à Tourer 6
mais j'avais oublié à chaque C4
avant de toute chose on va regarder et
l'idée en fait c'est que maintenant je
ne peux pas je pourrais le ça mais il y
aurait échec et ça et du coup bon
j'ai encore un fou et un pion qui peut
jouer contre la tour même si ça reste
gagnant je pense
et du coup l'idée de faire tour ici pour
empêcher ça mais c'est ça mais tours
c'est pas de menace à cause de fou échec